hey everyone welcome to simply launch
youtube channel in this session we will
be learning complete data structures
from scratch but before we begin let me
tell you guys that we have daily updates
on multiple technologies so if you're a
tech geek in a continuous hunt for
latest technological trends then
consider getting subscribed to our
youtube channel and don't forget to hit
that bell icon to never miss an update
from simply learn now without further
ado let's get started with the agenda
for today's session
we will begin with having a brief
introduction to data structures followed
by that we will understand what exactly
is time complexity after that we will
start understanding each and every data
structure starting from pointers in c
moving forward we will learn arrays in
data structures and then we will learn
the types of fires that is two
dimensional arrays and multi-dimensional
arrays
followed by that we will learn linked
list in data structures then the types
of linked lists that are singly linked
list doubly linked list and circular
linked list and after that we will dive
into stacks and data structures next
after stacks we will learn queues and
priority queues in data structures later
we will learn how to dequeue elements
from a queue data structure followed by
queues and dqs we will learn three data
structures
and in three data structures we will
understand tree traversal and later the
types of trees that is binary tree
binary search tree b plus tree etc
followed by trees we will understand
graphs and data structures next we will
learn spanning trees and spanning tree
implementation
so these are all the data structures
that we will be learning today now
without further ado let's get started
with the first topic that is
introduction to data structures
let's get started with the agenda for
today's session
first we look at the definition of data
structures after that we will understand
why we need data structures later we
will discuss the different types of data
structures
finally we will look at the importance
of data structures hope i made myself
clear with the agenda now let's get
started with our first concept that is
what are data structures
data is an information that has been
translated into a form that is efficient
to movement or processing in computing
as it relates to trades computers and
transmission media data is an
information that has been converted into
binary digital form the term raw data
refers to the data in its most basic
digital format after defining data let's
look at what data structure entails a
data structure is a data organization
management and storage format in
computer science that allows for
efficient access and modification or a
data structure is an algebraic structure
about data that contains a collection of
data values their relationships and
their functions or operations that can
be applied to the data we will now
understand why exactly we need data
structures now that we have already
defined what is a data structure
so let us have a look at some of the
data structure characteristics the first
one is each data structure allows data
to be stored differently following that
the data structure allows for more
efficient data search and retrieval then
specific data structures are chosen to
solve specific problems last but not the
least it enables the management of large
amounts of data such as large databases
and indexing services such as hash
tables
let us now look at some real-world
examples of data structures
first and the foremost we have the
dictionary assume that we are looking
for the word simply learn in the
dictionary
and we know it begins with the letter s
so we can search for this word beginning
with the letter s and then this is an
example of array data structure
as a result this dictionary can also
function like an array data structure
following by that we have a music player
example
if you have a playlist with three songs
the second song will play after the
first and the third will play after the
second so these will be played without
any interruption because all these three
songs are linked with each other using
linkless type of data structure
so followed by linked list the next
example we have is the data structures
the stack of books analogy is a perfect
example of the real-time working of the
stacked data structure subsequent to
that assume there is a line of people at
a ticket window and the person who comes
first gets the ticket
this particular movie window queue is an
example for the real time implementation
of queue data structure
last but not the least google maps
google map is the graph data structure
in which all the cities and states are
connected if we want to go from one
place to another there may be many ways
to do so so we can use some algorithms
to find the shortest path
as a result the google map is a perfect
example for the graph data structure
working analogy
following that we will look at some
different types of data structures in
this tutorial
so the first type is the linear data
structure
the elements in the linear data
structure are arranged subsequently one
after the other they are simple to
implement because the elements are
arranged in specific order
followed by the first type the second
type is the non-linear data structure
which we will be discussing a bit later
so in linear data structures we have
four different types the first one is
the array data structure memory elements
are arranged in a continuous order in
arrays
and arrays elements are of same type the
software program also determines the
type of elements that can be stored in
arrays so followed by arrays we have
linked list link lists are completely
similar to data structures data elements
in linked list data structure are linked
together by a series of nodes
furthermore each node contains the data
items as well as the address to the next
node the third data structure is the
stack data structure elements in a stack
data structure are stored using lifo
principle in other words the last
element stored in the stack is remote
first in stack operations can only be
performed in one end namely the top
and the last data structure is the queue
data structure
unlike stack queue data structure
operates in the fifo principle which
states that the first element stored in
the queue is remote first in a queue
insertion and deletion are carried out
from opposite ends now we will discuss
the second type of data structures which
are the non-linear data structures
the non-linear data structure is the
second type of data structure non-linear
data structures do not have elements in
any order as opposed to the linear data
structures instead they are arranged in
hierarchical order with one element
connected to one or more others
so the first one in the non-linear data
structures is the tree data structure a
tree data structure is built using nodes
and edges each element in the tree data
structure is called as node or vertex
each vertex or node is connected to the
other nodes or other vertices using
edges
and the second one in the list is the
graph data structure a graph data
structure is completely like a tree data
structure
it also has
the vertices and edges each vertex in a
graph data structure is connected using
edges the only difference between a tree
and graph is that in tree you can have n
number of vertices but in graph you will
have only two vertices
after discussing the graph data
structure we will move ahead into the
last segment of this tutorial that is
importance of data structures so the
first one data structures are widely
used in almost every aspect of computer
science both for simple and complex
computations
next data structures are used in all
areas of computer science including
artificial intelligence graphics big
data operating systems and much more
after that the data structures are an
essential component of many computer
algorithms because they allow
programmers to manage data efficiently
lastly a proper data structure of
selection can improve the efficiency of
a computer program or algorithm
introduction to time complexity
the time complexity of an algorithm is
the amount of time it takes to run as a
function of the length of that input
the length of the input determines how
many operation the algorithm will do
it will provide the information about
the variance increase or decrease in
execution time as the number of
operations in an algorithm increases or
decreases
next up types of time complexity
we will start with the constant time
complexity
then we will discuss linear
logarithmic
quadratic
time complexity
now let's have a look at them
in the detail
first
constant time complexity
when an algorithm is not reliant on the
input size n it is set to have constant
time of order
bigger of 1.
the runtime will always be the same
regardless of the input
as you can see in the code every line
has the runtime of 1
and they are all independent of any
input size so the runtime is always
constant
next up linear time complexity
when an algorithm's running time
increases linearly with the length of in
the input it is said to have linear time
complexity
when a function checks all the values in
an input data set it is said to have the
time complexity of order of big o of n
as you can see in the code the loop
depends on the size n
so the time complexity rose up to n
next up logarithmic time complexity
when an algorithm lowers the input data
in each step then it is said to have the
logarithmic time complexity
binary trees or binary search functions
are some of the algorithms with
logarithmic time complexity
as you can see in this code by finding
out the mid in every iteration the
runtime will decrease every step
making it approximately logarithmic
runtime
next up quadratic time complexity
when the execution time of algorithm
rises non-linearly up to n square with
the length of the input it is said to
have quadratic time complexity
in general net nested loops falls into
the quadratic time complexity order
where one loop takes big o of n and if
the function contains the loop inside
the loop then it multiplies
as you can see in this code because of
the nested loops the time complexity
rose to n square
now that you have the firm grasp of time
complexity and its type we will discuss
essential steps to evaluate the time
complexity
to understand this we will take an
example of fibonacci number
this code prints the fibonacci numbers
till n
we will divide this code into three
parts isolating all the loops that play
a significant role in altering the time
complexity
let's look at the first part
it consists of some independent
statement which gave
constraint time for each statement
next
let's move on to our next part that is
for loop
since this loop runs n times this will
give linear time complexity on n
next up the third part
which also has the constant time
complexity
now let's take a total of runtime
which comes out to be n plus 5
we will then discard the constant part
to find the time complexity
which does not affect the overall time
complexity
now we will have the final time
complexity of bigger of n
we have now discussed time complexity
and how to evaluate it
now let's have a look at the time
complexity of various algorithm
we will look at the time complexity of
insertion sort
merge sort quick sort
bubble sort
and some searching algorithms like
linear search and binary search
let's look at them in the detail
first up insertion sort
as you can see in this code we are using
nested loops
so in worst case its complexity comes
out to be n square
now in the best case scenario the
complexity will be linear time
complexity
next up
merge sort
in this case whether it is the worst
case or the best case it will always
remain and login
as every statement in this code will run
the same amount so no matter what its
time complexity will remain the same
next up quick sort
the time complexity of quick sort in the
best case is n login
n
and in the worst case it is
answer
next up bubble sort
as you can see in this code we are using
nested loops
so in the worst case its complexity
comes out to be n square
now in the best case scenario the time
complexity will become the linear time
complexity that is n
and after that we will discuss some of
the searching algorithms first up linear
search
in the best case scenario if the
statement to be searched is at the first
position then the time complexity will
come out to be constant
whereas in the worst case the time
complexity will come out to be n
finally binary search
in the best case scenario if the element
is to be searched is at the mid then the
time complexity will come out to be the
constant
whereas in the worst case scenario the
time complexity will come out to be big
of log n
we have now discussed the time
complexity and how to evaluate
and the time complexity of various
algorithm
now let's sum up what we have learned
from this session
first up the execution time increases
with the types of operations we make
using the inputs
next up the lesser the time complexity
the faster is the execution
finally if a code is of hundreds of
lines
then it takes a toll on the pc's
processor
so it is essential to check and reduce
the time complexity as much as we can
let's get started with what are pointers
a pointer is a variable that points to
an address of another variable
it is declared using a star symbol also
called asterisk
and then we allocate a memory of a
variable to it
we can access a variable's address using
the ampersand symbol in the same manner
as the pointer declaration let's write a
code
we will declare a variable a is equals
to 5
and a pointer ptr
then we will assign this variable a's
value to pointer ptr
now let's write a print statement to
directly access the variable's value
using variable name
let's write another print statement to
print the value of a using pointer
let's try and execute this program
as you can see we have successfully
accessed variables value using both
variable name and pointers
let's get back to our slides
now let's discuss different types of
pointers
first up null pointer
void pointer
while pointer
and dangling pointer
let's discuss these in details
first up null pointer
it is a kind of pointer that points to a
null memory
as you can see in the figure here is a
pointer which is pointing to a null
memory
to get a better understanding let's try
a simple program in the code editor
let's write a code
first we will declare a pointer where
then we will assign its value
to null
now let's try to print the statement
let's execute this
as you can see since this pointer points
to a null or nothing that's why it
doesn't print anything
let's get back to our slides next
void pointer
when a pointer is created with data type
void then this pointer is called void
pointer
if we want to print the variable's value
then we have to typecast this pointer to
avoid any error for better understanding
let's get back to the code editor and
try it with a simple code first we will
declare an integer variable a is equals
to 5
and avoid pointer ptr
now we will assign address of a to
pointer ptr
let's write a print statement to print
this pointer
let's run this program
as you can see we are getting an error
that's because we can't print a void
variable
in this we have to typecast this
variable to integer let's do this
we can typecast a variable like this
now let's print this
as you can see we can print it now
let's get back to our slides
next while pointer
when we create a pointer but don't
initialize it by assigning any memory to
it then this kind of pointer is called
while pointer
these pointers can be very tricky they
can even cause a program failure or a
segmentation fault
let's get back to the correlator and try
it with a simple code
first let's declare a pointer ptr
but
they will not assign it with any address
let's write a print statement to print
it
this time we will directly print it
let's execute this
as you can see we are not getting any
results because there is no value
assigned to it sometimes it may even
show segmentation error
let's get back to our slides
next dangling pointer
let's suppose there is a pointer p which
is pointing at a variable
now if we deal locate this memory using
a free function
then this pointer will point at a free
space or a non-existing memory
then this pointer will become a dangling
pointer
to get a better understanding of this
pointer let's try it with a simple code
let's declare a pointer ptr
here we will dynamically allocate memory
using a mail of function
to do this we will put int star
in a bracket
then
dialog function
and in another bracket we will put
memory size to be allocated
now let's declare a variable a
and assign its address to the pointer
now to make it a dangling pointer we
have to de-allocate the memory of this
pointer
we will use free function for that
now let's write a print statement to
print this pointer
let's execute it
as you can see since we have diallocated
its memory that's why it is pointing to
nothing hence it doesn't print anything
let's get back to our slides
till now we have discussed pointers ways
to access variables and types of
pointers
now let's talk about use cases of
pointers
we will talk about point to arithmetics
pointer to pointer array of pointers
call by value and call by reference
now let's dive right into it let's talk
about point to arithmetics we can use
four arithmetic operations on pointers
increment
decrement
addition or subtraction of an integer
from a pointer
since pointer operates on addresses it
only makes sense if we apply pointer
arithmetics on sequential data
structures like arrays or strings
let's discuss them in detail first up
increment
if we apply this operator on a pointer
then it will shift this pointer's
address to its sequential successor
as you can see in the figure as we
increment the pointer's value we shift
to the next index of the array
let's get back to the code editor and
try it with a simple program
let's declare an array of size 3.
let's give them some value
we will then declare a pointer
and assign it to the arrays first
element
now let's write a for loop to traverse
this array
in this for loop we will increment a
pointer's value
and
print this pointer's value to traverse
this array
let's try and execute this program
as you can see we have traversed this
complete error
let's get back to our slides
next decrement
if this operator is applied on a pointer
it will shift this pointer's address to
its sequential predecessor
as you can see in the figure as we
decrement this pointer we also shift to
arrays previous index
let's get back to the code editor and
try to implement it let's declare an
array of size 3
and assign it some values
now let's declare a pointer
and assign arrays last elements address
to it
now let's write a for loop
to traverse this array
in this for loop we will decrement the
pointers value
also we will keep printing this
pointer's value to travel this array
let's try and execute this program
as you can see we have traversed this
complete array from the back
let's get back to our slides
next the addition of an integer to a
pointer
if this operator is applied on a pointer
it will leak forward accordingly
if the integer is 2 and our pointer
points at the first element then the
pointer will sequentially skip one
element and shift to the next element
let's implement it in the code editor
let's declare an array of size 7.
and assign them some value
then declare a pointer
and assign it to the array's first
element
now let's take an integer n to add in
the pointer
now let's write a for loop to traverse
this array
in this folder we will increment the
pointer's value with integer n
and we will keep printing the pointer
ptr value
let's execute this code
as you can see we have traversed this
complete array skipping one element at a
time
since we have skipped three elements
that's why we are getting last three
values as garbage values
let's get back to our slides
next
subtraction of an integer from a pointer
if this operator is applied on a pointer
then accordingly it will leap backward
if the integer is 2 and our pointer
points at the last element
then the pointer will skip one element
and shift to the previous element
let's try and implement it in the code
editor
first let's declare an array of size 7.
and assign it some values
then declare a pointer ptr
and assign it to the array's last
element
now let's take an integer n to subtract
from the pointer
now let's write a for loop to traverse
this array
[Music]
in this for loop we will decrement the
pointer's value with integer n
also we will write and print statement
to print this ptr's value
now let's try and execute this program
as you can see we have traversed this
complete array from back skipping one
element at a time
since we have skipped three elements
that's why we are getting last three
values as garbage values
let's get back to our slides
let's talk about precedence of these
operators
operator asterisk and ampersand have the
same priority as the unary operator
increment and decrement
these operators are evaluated from right
to left let's understand this concept
with an example
suppose if a pointer p points to a
variable x then we can swap x with
pointer p in that expression
in the first row we have y is equal to x
plus 1 which means we are storing an
incremented value of x in y similarly if
we replace x with a pointer p we can
store incremented value of pointer in y
in row 2 and row 3 we are incrementing x
and storing incremented value in x
itself
we can do this with pointers as well
in row 4 we are attempting to execute
pre-increment with a pointer p
in row 5 we are attempting to execute
post increment with pointer p
here we have to put star p in braces
because these operators are evaluated
from right to left
so to give more priority to pointer p we
have to use braces as they have highest
priority
let's talk about another use case
pointer to pointer
basically in this situation a pointer
will point at a variable via another
pointer
we declare it with two statistic symbol
let's discuss it with an example
suppose a pointer 1 points to a variable
and another pointer 2 points to that
pointer 1
this way pointer 2 will indirectly be
pointing to the variable
let's go to the code editor and try
implementing it
first we will declare a variable where
a pointer ptr1
and a pointer to this pointer ptr2
then we will assign this variable vars
address to ptr1
and
ptr1s address to ptr2
now we will write a print statement to
print variable var ptr1 and ptr2
now let's try and execute this program
as you can see
ptr1 and ptr2 shows variable vars value
as ptr2 is pointing to ptr1 and ptr1 is
pointing to that variable so indirectly
ptr2 points to the variable var
thus it prints the variable's value
let's get back to our slides
let's discuss the array of pointers
as the name suggests it is an array that
has all its elements as pointers
these pointers can be pointing at
another array it is declared as an array
with asterisk symbol
let's discuss it with the program
first we will declare an array a of size
3.
then we will declare
a pointer array ptr of size 3.
now we will write a for loop to assign
a's elements address to ptr's element
then we will write another for loop to
traverse ptr and print its element
foreign
let's try and execute this program
as you can see it prints the value of
arraya's elements because error ptrs
elements are pointing to arrays elements
let's get back to our slides
next call by value
we don't use pointers in this concept
but it is very important to understand
this concept to get better understanding
of the next topic call by reference
in call by value we call a function
and directly pass the variable's value
as parameters
in this situation a copy of those
variable is created and get passed into
a function as parameters
if we modify these parameters it will
not affect actual variables rather these
copies will get deleted as soon as the
function body ends
let's try implementing it in the code
editor
let's write a code
first we will declare a variable x
equals to hundred
then we will write a function called to
function func with argument x
next we will write a print statement to
check if any changes happen due to the
function
now let's write definition for this
function
we will take a void function
with argument as x
in this first we will set x equals to
200
and then we will write a print statement
to print this value
let's try and execute this program
as you can see here when we get back to
the main block from function its value
again reverted back to 10
because in call by value program we only
pass variables copy into the function
not the actual variables
let's get back to our slides
next
call by reference
in this if we call a function but this
time we pass the variables address as
parameters
then in this situation actual variables
will get passed into the function as
parameters
if we modify these parameters it will
modify the actual variables even outside
the function scope
let's try implementing it in the code
editor
first we will declare a variable int x
equals to 100
next we will write a function call for
function func
with argument as address of x
then we will write a print statement to
check if any changes happen due to the
function
now let's write definition for this
function
it will be a void function
with argument as pointer x
in this we will first set x equals to
200
then we will write a print statement to
print this value of x
now let's try and execute this program
as you can see this time variable access
value didn't revert to hundred that's
because in call by reference we pass
actual variables address two functions
so it will modify them as well
let's get back to our slides
during the course of this video we have
learnt a lot about pointers let's
discuss some advantages of the pointers
first up pointers are useful to access a
memory location pointers are also an
effective way to access the array
elements
pointers are used for the dynamic memory
allocation and its distribution
pointers are also used to build complex
data structures like linked list graph
tree stack queue etc
now let's talk about some disadvantages
as well
first up pointers are difficult to
understand so a programmer needs to be
careful while handling them
they might raise some errors like
segmentation error or access some
unrequired memory and cause program
failure
if a pointer is pointing to an incorrect
value then it might corrupt memory
pointers may also cause memory leakage
also pointers are slower than variables
at last let's sum up what we have
learned in this session with key
takeaways
first up a pointer is simply a storage
location for a data in a memory
we can use pointers to traverse array
more efficiently
we can also use function pointers to
call a function dynamically
we can perform arithmetic operations on
pointers as well
when we define an array of pointers its
elements can also points to function
making it easier to call different
function at once
why did we actually need an array
so to understand this let's go through a
simple concept
let us imagine that we have some data
and the data is related to students
right so if we wanted to store the marks
of individual students then we had to
declare a variable for each of the
student
so you can see we have student 1 student
2 student 3 4 and 5 and their individual
scores so the score 1 is assigned to
student 1 and so on with student 5 being
assigned to score 5.
so in the real time this might be a
little clumsy we have here just five
students so that is okay but what if we
had 500 students or 5 000 students right
that might be an issue there we have to
create some 500 or 5 000 variables and
it would be a little tough to handle
that right even if we wanted to apply
some operations collectively on all the
variables that might be a little tedious
so what if we had one variable which
could store all the 5 students or 500
students or 5 000 students all together
and make it really easy for us to apply
some operations collectively on all the
students right this sounds a little bit
logical
so similarly we do have a data structure
which can do that which can collectively
store all the data elements in it as a
single variable and it will also help us
to apply the operations which are
logical or mathematical on all the
variables and their values together as a
whole so that is the purpose why we had
created arrays that is the purpose why
we needed arrays
so far we have understood what was the
necessity for aries now we will
understand what exactly are arrays
so basically an array is a linear data
structure that stores the elements in a
sequential manner one after the other
and when you declare an array the
variables will be stored one besides the
other that is adjacent to each other in
a sequential order now let us understand
how the array is represented by the
compiler
now the next part that is the memory
representation of aries
now let us imagine that we have declared
an array which stores character type
data and another important point to
remember about r is when you declare an
array it stores only a single data type
typed elements only for example here we
have declared a character type array
right so we cannot store integer type
data or flow type data in it we only
have to save character type array or
character type elements in this
particular array
so now let us imagine that we have
created an array which is of character
data type and these are the elements
which are a r r a y now how does the
compiler represent it in the form of
memory
so when you create an array
these are formed that is the index
values and the address so basically
compiler will select a block of memory
and it has addresses to that block and
it can be anything right here we have 11
12 13 14 and 15 and in real time it
might be a thousand one thousand two
thousand three thousand four thousand
five the main motto is assign a
sequential block of memory and this is
the array and the elements are a r r a y
and this particular one which is the
last one is the index of the array that
is the position of the array for user so
using this index you can access the
elements in the array more on that in
the accessing part
so let us imagine that we wanted to
access the element r so how to access it
we might not know the address right in
that instance we will use the index this
is for our reference
so we will tell i want the element from
array index number 2 and then we'll have
the ar
r element so in the practical form this
is how we use the index
now let's continue with the lower bound
and the upper bound so the first initial
location is called as the lower bound
and at the last or the max value of the
array is called as the upper bound now
let us jump into the next topic where we
will understand the different types of
arrays
so these are the different types of
arrays
one dimensional arrays and
multi-dimensional arrays
in multi-dimensional arrays we have two
more types that is two dimensional
arrays and three dimensional arrays
so how are arrays different from each
other
right so the first one will deal with
the first one that is the one
dimensional array now how is an array
declared as one dimensional for that we
need subscript
so one dimensional array requires only
one subscript to specify the number of
elements in an array so how is it
actually represented so here you can see
an example right on my screen
so here is how a one dimensional array
looks like so here we have the data type
that is integer data type and marks is
the name of the array and this is the
size of the array and here the elements
will be stored
and here it is the index value of the
array and remember the index value of
array always starts from zero in the
previous example that was only for basic
understanding so i just started that
with one in the practical way the array
index always starts from zero
so followed by the one dimensional array
we will deal with the multi-dimensional
arrays in that we have the following
the first one is the two-dimensional
array and the second one is the
three-dimensional array
in the multi-dimensional arrays we
require more than one subscript
in the previous example we had one
dimensional array so the subscript is
just one that is ten columns
right so we just had one single row and
ten different columns but in the
multi-dimensional arrays we need
multiple rows and multiple columns
right so we need two subscripts for two
dimensional array and
more than two subscripts for three
dimensional arrays
so first we have the two dimensional
arrays
the 2d array is organized in the form of
a matrix which can be represented as a
collection of rows and columns so here
is the example
as you can see on my screen we have
three columns and three rows
and we have two subscripts that define
the number of rows and the number of
columns and the elements in each and
every row so the one two three confines
the first row four five six confines the
second row and 7 8 9 will be the third
row
now similarly we have three dimensional
arrays a 3d array is a collection of 2d
arrays which consists of three
subscripts block size row size and
column size
so here we have an example for that
so we have three subscripts that is the
first one is block size the second one
is the row number and the third one is
column number
so this happens to be the first block
this happens to be the second block and
this is how a three-dimensional array
can be represented
now we have the next stage where we will
understand how to declare the arrays and
the syntax is right on my screen you
need to specify the data type of the
array which is integer float or
character any selection which you make
followed by that you need to select an
array name for your array and inside
that you need to declare the array size
and sometimes you can also eliminate the
array size if you wanted to you know
have a dynamic array
and here is an example for that
you have integer data type name of the
array is example and the array size is
6.
so the compiler will allocate continuous
memory block of 6 integer type blocks
so these are the few more methods to
initialize the array
so here you can see integer data type
array name is a element size is five and
we have five elements
the method two is remember i have said
you can eliminate the size of the array
right so here you can use this way as
well integer data type array name a and
no size here and you can directly
declare the elements
and the method third so here you have
the name of the array size of the array
and you are allocating the elements to
the individual memory locations there is
also another method to initialize array
and method for is using a forum you can
just initialize a for loop and the i
value will be stored in the array
locations starting from 0.
now let us understand how to access the
elements in an array
so to access the elements in an array
you need to specify the name of the
array and memory block where you have
that element that you want to access so
here we have an example
which is integer data type name of the
array is x y z and the element we wanted
to access is 5 so here we have an
example that is integer type array array
name is xyz and it has the size 5.
and now we wanted to access the first
element in an array that can be done
using the first index that is x y z of
zero index that is the first element and
accessing the second element and so on x
y z top one will be the second element x
y set of two three four will be the
third and fourth and fifth elements
now let us understand some basic
operations that can be performed on the
array elements
so the following are the operations that
can be performed on the array elements
that is the traversal insertion
deletion searching and sorting
now let us get into practical mode and
try to execute some examples based on
traversal of the array insertion of an
element into the array deletion of an
element from an array searching for an
element in an array and sorting the
complete array so at first we'll carry
out the traversal operation so here we
have an array that is a of 5 and the
elements are 1 2 3 4 and 5. now we're
going to use a for loop to traverse
through this array and print all the
elements sequentially now let us execute
this code and see the output
so as you can see the code got
successfully executed and the elements
that is 1 2 3 4 and 5 from the array a
are printed sequentially
now moving ahead we'll try to execute
some examples based on insertion of
element into the array so on my screen
you can see an example for inserting an
element into the array at the starting
position of the array now let us try to
execute this code and see the output
don't worry about the codes these code
documents will be attached in the
description box below and you will be
able to have an access to it and run
these codes in your personal laptop and
get a better learning experience
now you can see the code got
successfully executed and now it is
asking for the size of the array let's
declare it as 5
and now let's enter the elements into
the array
now it is asking for the element to be
added at the beginning of the array now
we have 2 3 4 5 and 6 existing in the
array let's add the first element 1
and there you go the resultant array is
1 2 3 4 5 and 6. the element which we
added at the ending which is one is
supposed to be in the first or the
beginning part of the array which is
here at at the first index location as
planned now let's get started with
another example on the insertion
now let's try to insert an element at
any given location as per the user's
choice
so as you can see we have a program on
my screen and running this program must
help us to insert an element into any
given location of the array
now let's try to quickly run this
program and see the output
so there you go enter the elements into
the array
let's enter 1 3
let's try to run this program and see
the output
so there you go the program got
successfully executed and now the output
is asking for us to tell it the number
of elements in an array now let's say
four elements
so now let's enter the four elements
one
three
four five and six
okay
so the four elements which is one three
four five are been inserted now it is
asking for the location where you want
to insert the element now let us insert
it in this second location
now let us set the value as two
and there you go the resultant array is
one two three four and 5 and the element
which is 2 was supposed to be added in
the second location and it has been
successfully added now let's try to
execute another example based on
insertion where you will try to insert
the element in the last position
now this program on my screen will help
us to add an element at the end of the
array let's quickly run this program
now it is asking for us to enter the
five elements of the array let's enter
that
now it is asking to enter the element to
be inserted now let us enter the element
and this element should be added at the
end location as discussed
the resultant array is one three five
seven nine and eleven
now let's continue with the deletion
operation
now the program on my screen is an
example for deleting an element from the
beginning position of an array now the
program got successfully executed and
it's asking for us to enter the size of
the array let's enter the size as 5
and now let's enter the elements of the
array that is 1
2 3
4 and 5.
now the element from the first location
that is 1 has been deleted and the
resultant array is 2 3 4 and 5. now the
code on my screen will help you to
eliminate the element from the ending
location of an array now let's try to
quickly run this program and say the
object
so you can see that the program is
successfully run and it is asking for us
to enter the size of the array let's
enter 4. now let's enter the elements of
the array that is 1 2 3 and 4.
now after eliminating the last element
from the array that is 4 we have the
resultant array that is 1 2 and 3.
now a little hover for you guys let's
try to execute an example for deleting
an element from any location of an array
this will be a homework now don't worry
try on your own and if you don't get
that you can refer to the comment
sections below where you have the code
document attached in the description box
and you can refer to it
now let's continue with the next
operation where we will search for a
given element in the array
so you can see that on my screen we have
an example which will help us to sort
the elements in an array let's quickly
run this
so there you go the program got
successfully executed and now it's
asking for the array size let's enter
five
and now let's enter the elements in a
random order
[Music]
now the resultant array should be sorted
so there you go the array after being
sort is it's 2 3 5 14 and 21
so there you go the array got sorted so
now we have finished our practical
session let's have a quick overview
again so traversal in an array is a
process of visiting each element once
traversal can be done by various means
that is by counting the array elements
printing the values sorted in the arrays
and sum of all elements present in the
array and many more
so this is how we traverse our array
from the first location to the last
location again the insertion operation
insertion in an array is the process of
including one or more elements in an
array and it can be done at the
beginning at the end and at any given
index of an array which we executed for
all the three types of examples
now next we have the deletion operation
so deletion operation or deletion of an
element is a process of removing a
desired element and reorganizing the
array and it can be done at the
beginning at the end and at any given
index so we have executed the example
for at the beginning and at the end and
the homework was at the given index
don't worry if you don't figure it out
you can always refer to the example
document which is mentioned in the
description box below
now the search operation searching is a
process of finding a given value in the
list of values and it decides whether
the search key is present in the array
or not and we have executed an example
on that
and again the sort operation where we
will sort the given array
if the given array is not in the default
order or in a given order that is
ascending or descending then we can sort
the order of the array by the user's
choice given it is ascending order or
descending order
now in the next section of the tutorial
we will discuss the advantages of using
arrays
so the first one is array stores
multiple elements of same data type with
same name
next one elements in an array can be
accessed randomly using just the index
number
array memory is predefined so there is
no extra memory loss
array avoids memory overflow and finally
2d arrays can represent the tabular form
of data in a very efficient way
now let us also have a look on some of
the disadvantages of using arrays
the first one the number of elements in
an array should be always predefined so
there is no chance that you can add some
extra element in the last moment
array is static in nature so its size
cannot be varied after declaration
what if consider that you wanted to
store 10 student data in one array and
you end up having just seven students so
the remaining three is a waste right so
you are wasting memory there that's the
problem and insertion and deletion
operations in an array is quite
difficult as the array stores elements
in a continuous form
and finally allocating excess memory
then required mainly to memory wastage
now we have the final key takeaways of
the arrays
so we discussed why do we need arrays
then we discussed what are arrays
followed by that we discussed types of
arrays next we had a declaration of
arrays accessing elements from an array
initializing the arrays and basic
operations on array that is the
practical demo part and finally we have
discussed the advantages and
disadvantages of using an array what are
arrays
so we will see a brief definition of
arrays
the array is a data structure that
stores elements of the same data type in
a sequential order
two dimensional arrays are considered as
an array of arrays
two-dimensional arrays represent the
information in the form of rows and
columns which is completely similar to a
tabular form of data following by the
definition and briefing of the two
dimensional arrays
we will understand the need for two
dimensional arrays
so the main advantage of using a two
dimensional array is the elements can be
represented in the form of a matrix that
is rows and columns
using two-dimensional arrays
we can initialize access and print
multiple elements in the matrix form by
just running one single quote segment
you can see an example right on my
screen here
this is an example of marks list suppose
a class has three subjects namely
english science and maths
we have four students and we wanted to
represent the data in the form of a
database so here the marks of the four
students can be represented using two
dimensional arrays
now we will see the syntax of a
two-dimensional array so here the syntax
at first we need the data type the data
type can be integer character float
string etc then we have the name for the
two-dimensional array and later we can
have two subscripts which represent two
dimensions that is the rows and columns
the first subscript defines the number
of rows and the second subscript defines
the number of columns and note that the
column number can never be null
at the end we have a semicolon to
terminate the syntax
and here we have some examples of two
dimensional arrays so in the first
example we have the name of the two
dimensional array and we have
three rows and four columns
and followed by that we have another
example which is of character data type
and the name of the array is names and
we have 7 rows and 15 columns
next we will see how to visualize two
dimensional arrays
we read earlier that two-dimensional
arrays are a collection of rows and
columns let's see an example of two
dimensional array
we will consider an array with six rows
and four columns
as you can see on my screen we have
integer type array and the name of the
array is array and we have six rows and
four columns
the product of rows and columns will
give us the total number of elements
present in a two dimensional array
in the current example
we have 6 rows and 4 columns and the
product is 24 so we must have 24
elements in this array
next we will see how to initialize two
dimensional arrays
so there are two ways to initialize a
two-dimensional array so in the first
method we declare the elements in the
set of curly brackets
this array consists of three rows and
three columns
note that the index always starts from
zero here we have three rows it means
the row starts with zero and ends with
two
the same goes for the column but
sometimes this method might be a little
confusing so we have a better method the
advantage of this method is clarity
we can visualize all the elements with
better clarity compared to the previous
method so the first three elements are
9
six
and one
they are present in the first row
and in the second row we have
144 70 and 50. they comprise the second
row and finally the third row in which
the elements are 10 12 and 78
so far we have learned how to visualize
and initialize a two dimensional array
so we have done it by using the index
values that is the row index and the
column index so the row index value was
three and the column index value was
three for accessing an element in the
two-dimensional array we need to pass
the name of the two-dimensional array
followed by the row index value and the
column index value for example let us
assume that we wanted to access the
element 9 for doing so we will pass the
name of the array followed by the row
index value and the column index value
as shown below that is end first zero
comma zero
and an important point here is indexing
always starts with zero
we will now start printing the two
dimensional arrays
so to print a two-dimensional array we
will be using two nested for loops
so to understand the process of printing
the two-dimensional array let's get back
to the practical mode and we will work
on a code
so on my screen you can see an example
for two-dimensional adding so here we
have declared an array with the name
first and we have three rows and three
columns and inside that the first row of
elements is 961 and the second row of
elements is 144 70 and 50 and the third
row of elements is 10 12 and 78
followed by that we have two counter
variables which are i and j
so we are using the first counter
variable i in the order for loop and the
second counter variable j in the second
in the form
and inside the inner follow we have a
print statement which is used to print
the elements in the array
now
let us try to execute this code and see
the output
so you can see the code got successfully
compiled and we have our elements here
which is 961 144 70 50 10 12 and 78 now
let us understand the logic
so here we have declared the counter
variable as 0 and the condition is i
should be less than 3 which is true so
the control will enter into the second
inner for loop here we have j is equals
to 0 and j should be less than 3 which
is true so here the condition or the
statement
is valid and it will print the first
element 9.
followed by that j will be incremented
again j is now equals to 1 and j is less
than 3 so again we'll print the second
element 6.
again j value will be incremented to 2
so 2 is less than 3 then we will print
the third element that is
1.
now when you increment the value of j
from 2 to 3 the condition will fail
because 3 cannot be less than 3
so the control will enter into the outer
for loop here we have i value is equals
to 0 which will be incremented to 1.
so 1 is less than 3 again the control
will enter the inner follow here again
we will check for j is equals to 0 which
is true so we will print the second row
of elements that is 144 70 50 in the
same way how we printed the first row
right so j will be equals to 0 so then
we'll print the first element so j will
be incremented to
1 and 1 is less than 3 then we will
print the second element that is 17 and
again j will be incremented to 2
and 2 is less than 3 so we will print
the third element that is 50 in the
second row
and again j will be incremented to three
now the compilation of the condition
will result in false so it will exit the
second follow-up and but it will come
back to the first outer for loop now the
value of i will be incremented to 2 so 2
is less than 3 the control will enter
into the inner for loop again then we
will print the third row of elements
that is 10 12 and 78 in the same way how
we printed the first row and the second
row after printing the third row the
condition will fail when j value is
incremented to 3 and it will enter the
order for loop here the i value will be
incremented again from 2 to 3 and the
condition fails now the overall control
will come out of both the for loops and
it will terminate here
so that's how we got 9 6 1 44 70 50 10
12 and 78 so with that we have come to
the conclusion and so far we have
learned the following things
what are two dimensional arrays why we
need two dimensional arrays syntax of 2d
arrays visualizing 2d arrays
initializing 2d arrays accessing 2d
elements and finally print the elements
of two dimensional arrays let's get
started with what is linked list
a linked list is a linear data structure
made up of nodes these nodes consist of
two parts data and reference to another
pointer
typically a linked list starts with a
head node which goes all the way up to
the last node which is called tail
next let's discuss why do we need linked
list
a linked list is a linear data structure
like arrays but an array can only offer
a fixed size whereas a linked list can
dynamically increase its size
also operations like insertion and
deletion are much easier in a linked
list than in an array
now let's try to implement the linked
list in the code editor
let's start by creating a node
to create a node we need a class
let's declare a class node
we will declare its member as public
the first member is end data
and the second member is node
pointer
next
now we will go into the main block and
initialize our first node
to initialize a node we need to use node
star
the node name had
equals to
similarly we will
create more nodes
and our last node
now we will allocate these four nodes in
the heap
to do that we will use a node name
equals to new node
star
new node
braces
now we will allocate all the nodes in
the same manner
now we will assign data to our first
node
to access the member of the node class
we will use error formation
then we will use data
equals to
let's give it a value as 2.
now we will link this first node with
our second node to do that we will use
head
same error formation
and next
which will be equals to
our
n1 node
and now we have
created our first complete node
now let's create other nodes as well
n1 arrow
data
is equals to
let's give it three
and one arrow
next
is equals to n2
and two arrow
data
is equals to
five
and to arrow
next
to arrow
next
is equals to
tail
now
tail is equal still arrow data
equals to seven
and
tail
arrow
next
is given
null
now let's call up function to print this
list
we will give hat as the argument
as
we can only traverse a linked list from
its head
let's write a definition for this print
list function
this function will be a void function
argument is
node star
a
we will use while loop to traverse this
linked list
we will give it
condition
if a is not equals to
null
then
see out
yes
a data
and l
now we will change
our cursor from the current node to the
next node to do that we will use
a is goes to a arrow next
now let's try to execute this code
as you can see we have traversed our
complete linked list
now let's get back to our slides
now let's discuss different types of
linked list
the first of single linked list
next is the doubly linked list
the circular linked list and finally we
have the circular doubly linked list
let's discuss each one of these in
details
first up single linked list
it is a unidirectional linked list
while using the sinclair link list we
can only traverse it in one direction
that is from head node to the tail node
next up doubly linked list
it is a bi-directional linked list we
can traverse it in both the directions
in this linked list the node has an
additional pointer that points to the
previous node
next up circular linked list
it is a regular linked list except for
its last node points to the head node
programmer needs to be careful while
traversing it or they might get stuck in
an infinite loop
next up the circular doubly linked list
it is a combination of doubly linked
list and a circular linked list
its last node points at the head node
and the previous pointer of the head
node points to the last node
it is also bidirectional linked list so
that we can traverse it in both
directions we have now discussed the
linked list why do we need linked lists
and types of linked list now let's learn
about some operation we can apply on
linked list
we can use majorly two operations on
linked list
first up insertion
and deletion
we can perform these operations in three
different situations
first at the beginning
at the last or at a specific position
after a node
next we will discuss these operations in
detail
first up insertion
we will discuss first session at the
beginning
we have to give the first notes address
to the new nodes next pointer to execute
this
next up insertion at the end
we have to give the new node's address
to the last node's reference pointer
next up in session at a specific
position
to do this we will have to change the
reference address of the previous node
to the new node's address
and the new node's reference pointer to
the next node's address
now let's discuss deletion
first up deletion at the beginning
we have to change the first node's
address to the null to execute this
next up deletion at the end
we have to change the second last node's
address to the null
next up deletion at a specific position
we will change the reference address of
the previous node to the next node's
address
we have learnt a lot about linked list
during this session
now let's discuss some benefits of
linked list
first up a linked list is a dynamic data
structure
that is we can dynamically increase its
size
next it offers easy insertion and
deletion
than other linear data structures like
arrays and string
since it can dynamically increase its
size resulting in no memory base stage
next
it is pretty handy in implementing
complex data structures like stacks and
queues etc
now let's talk about some disadvantages
as well
first up since the linked list is made
up of nodes it takes extra storage for
storing data and reference pointer
next the traversal in the linked list is
a bit harder than other data structure
reverse traversing is easy in doubly and
circular doubly linked list but since it
uses one extra pointer it takes extra
storage making it another limitation
at last let's sum up what we have
learned in this session with key
takeaways
first up we have recognized linked list
as a dynamic data structure
next a linked list offers faster
insertion and deletion operation
next
linked list traversal is hard because we
have to start from the head node every
time
finally a linked list is an asset in
implementing other data structures like
stacks and queues let's get started with
introduction to single linked list
a single linked list is a linear data
structure made up of nodes
these nodes consist of two parts
data
and reference to the another pointer
these nodes can be traversed using
pointers
it starts from the head node all the way
up to
tail node
now let's try to implement the singly
linked list in the code editor start by
creating a node
to create a node we need a class
let's declare a class node
we will declare its member as public
the first member is end data
and the second member is node
pointer next
now we will go into the main block and
initialize our first node
to initialize a node we need to use node
star
the node name had
equals to
similarly we will
create more nodes
and at last repeat and our last node
tail
now we will allocate these four nodes in
the heap to do that we will use
a node name
equals to
new node
star
new node
braces
now we will allocate all the nodes in
the same manner
now we will assign data to our first
node
to access the member of the node class
we will use error formation
then we will use data
equals to
let's give it a value as 2.
now we will link this first node with
our second node
to do that we will use
head
same error formation
and next
which will be equals to
our
n1 node
and now we have created our first
complete node
now let's create other nodes as well
n1 arrow
data
is equals to
let's give it three
and one arrow
next
is equals to
n2
and two arrow
data
is equals to
five
and two arrow
next
to arrow
next
is equals to
tail
now
tail is equal still arrow data
equals to 7
and
tail arrow
next
is given
null
now let's call up function to print this
list
we will give head as the argument
as
we can only traverse a linked list from
its head
let's write a definition for this print
list function
this function will be a void function
argument is
node star
a
we will use while loop to traverse this
linked list
we will give it
it condition if a is not equals to
null
then
c out
is
a data
and l
now
we will change
now we will change
our cursor
from the current node to the next node
to do that we will use a is equals to a
arrow next
now let's try to execute this code
as you can see we have traversed our
complete linked list
now let's get back to our slides
we have now introduced the singly linked
list
now let's discuss some of the operations
we can apply on a linked list
first up insertion
we can perform insertion at three
different situations
like at the beginning at the last or at
a specific position after a node
next up deletion
similar to the insertion we can perform
it in three different situation as well
at the beginning at the last or at a
specific position after a node
let's talk about them in detail first up
insertion at the beginning
to execute this we have to give first
node's address to the new node's next
pointer
next up insertion at the end
to execute this we have to give new
nodes address to the last node's next
address
next up insertion at a specific position
to execute this we will change the
previous node's reference address to the
new node's address and the new nodes
reference pointer to the next node
address now let's try these operations
in a code editor as you know a linked
list is made up of node so we should
start by creating a node to create a
node we need a class
node
and we will define its members as public
print
data
and
node pointer
next
now we will create a function to insert
a new node in front of the list
for this function as an argument we will
give the reference to the head of the
list
and integer dot new data
in the definition we will allocate a
node
newnode equals to
now we will put in the data in the new
node
we will use arrows to put to access the
data
equals to
new
now we will make the next of this new
node as head
now we will move the head to point to
the new node
now we will create another function to
insert a node after a specific position
as arguments we will give it
the address to the previous node
and
the integer new data
we will first check if the given
previous node is null
it is we will print
given note
and not
and then we will return the function
otherwise
otherwise we will allocate a new node
and then we will enter the new data
now we will make the next of the new
node as a next of the previous node
and then we will move the next of the
previous nodes
as new node
now we will write a function to insert a
node at the end of the list
as an argument we will give it
a node pointer to
pointer and
integer new data
we will first allocate a new node
we will also create a last node
and give it
now we will put in the data in the new
node
since this new node is going to be the
last node so we will make its next as
null
now if the linked list is empty then
we'll make the new node as head
to check that we will use
if
starhead
is equals to equals to null
if it is then we will do
star head
equals to new node
else
we will traverse it to the last node
while
last
next
not null
last
is equals to
fast
next
now we will change the next of the last
node as new node
now we will write a function to print
this list
bye
node is not null
load
arrow
data
and then
and node
equals to
node
now we will write the code for the main
block
first we will define a head node
and mark it as null
now we will start using those functions
to make a linked list
first we will use append function
to add
six in it
next let's let's use another function
push
and add 7 in it
now we will try to insert one at the
beginning
so we will use push again
comma one
now let's try to insert four at the end
so far the list looks like one seven six
four null
now let's
let's try to insert eight after seven
to do that we will use insert
after
as argument we will use head next as 7
is present next to the head
comma
eight
now let's try to print this linked list
see out
created
then
yes
list
add
return
let's execute this
as you can see we have created the
linked list in the correct order
let's get back to our slides now let's
talk about deletion first up deletion at
the beginning
to execute this we have to change first
node's next address to null
next up deletion at the end
to execute this we have to change the
second last node's address to the null
next up deletion at the specific
position
we will change the previous node's
reference address to the next node's
address
now let's try these operations in a code
editor
we will start by creating a class
node
in this class we will declare the
members as public
print
data
and the node pointer next
now to insert the data in the node we
will use
a function
push
as argument we will give pointer to
pointer node
header
and
integer new data
we will allocate a new node
we will give this new node the data as
new data
and
and new notes next as head
now we will write a function to delete
the node
as argument we will give a node pointer
to pointer
head
and end key
now we will store head in a temp node
and we will create a node
as null
if head node itself holds the key to be
deleted we will use if
amp is not equals to
null
and temp
data
is equal to equals to key
then head
equals to
next
now we will free the old node
else we will search for the key to be
deleted
while
amp
is not equals to
and
temp data
is not key
so prev
equals to temp
and temp
will be hydrated to its next
if
the key is not present in the linked
list
then we will just return the function
else we will unlink the node from the
linked list
and
delete
now we will write a print list function
to print the list
its argument will be a node pointer node
while
a node is not null
layout
less than
node
data
and we will iterate this node
using node equals to
node
next
now we will move on to the main block
we will start with the empty list
node
star
head
equals to null
now we will add the element to this list
so push
ampersand
head
comma 7
next push
head
comma
2
push
next push
ampersand
add
comma
9
now see out
created
test
and list
add
now we will use delete node function
delete
two
we will use argument as
ampersand head comma
2
now
we will check the linked list
of
two
print
tests
let's try and execute this
as you can see we have deleted the two
from the linked list
let's get back to our slides
at last let's sum up what we have learnt
in this session first up we have
recognized singly linked list as dynamic
data structure
next up the single link lists offer
faster insertion and deletion operation
next
single linked lists are unidirectional
linked list that is you can only
traverse it in one direction
finally a single linked list is an asset
in implementing other data structures
like stacks and queues let's get started
with an introduction to double a link
list
a w link list is a linear data structure
made up of nodes
this linked list is a bi-directional
linked list that is we can traverse it
in both direction
these nodes consist of three parts first
up data reference to the next node and
reference to the previous node
now let's try to implement the doubly
linked list in the code editor
as you know a linked list is made up of
nodes so we will start by creating a
node to create a node we need a class
node
its members should be defined as public
hint data
node pointer
next
and node pointer
now we will write a function to insert a
node at the beginning of the doubly
linked list
void
push
argument will be a node pointer to
pointer
add
and
end new data
now let's allocate a node
node star
new node
equals
new
node
now let's put in the data into the new
node
since we are adding at the beginning its
previous is always null
now we will link the old list of the new
now we will change the previous of the
head node to the new node
we will check if head is not null
then heads previous
is equals to
new node
now let's move the head to the point to
the new node
now let's write a function to print the
given double linked list
its argument will be a node
we will iterate it until the node is not
null
layout
node data
and
and
node
equals to
node next
now let's write a code for the main
block
we will start with the empty list
now we will use a push function to push
values in the function
another push function
add
comma
3
push function
ampersand
had
comma 5
push function
add
comma seven
now
p out
doubling
and list
then we will call the print list
function
in the double linked list
let's execute this program
as you can see we have successfully
created our first doubly linked list
let's get back to our slides
we have now introduced doubly linked
list
now let's discuss some of the operations
we can perform on a doubly linked list
we can perform three operations on a
doubly linked list
first traversal
insertion
and deletion
we can perform a traversal in two ways a
normal traversal and reverse traversal
and we can perform insertion and
deletion in three different situations
at the beginning at the last and at a
specific position after a node
let's discuss these in detail first up
normal traversal
we can traverse the doubly linked list
using a next pointer starting from head
to all the way up to tail node
reverse traversal similar to the normal
traversal we will use previous pointer
we will start from the tail node to go
all the way up to head node
now let's try to traverse the doubly
linked list in the code editor
let's start by creating a class
node will define its members as public
print data
node pointer
next
and node pointer
pref
now we will write a function to insert a
node at the beginning of the way link
list
right push
its argument will be a node pointer to
pointer head
and integer new data
now we will allocate a node
new node
new
node parenthesis
now we will put in the data
since we are adding at the beginning so
its prep is always null
now we will link the old node to the new
node
now we will change the previous of the
head node to the new node
now we will move the head to the point
to the new node
now we will write a function to traverse
the linked list normally
voip
traverse
node pointer
while loop
node
is not null
therefore
data
node
equals to node next
now we will write a function to reverse
traverse it
its argument will be a note pointer to
pointer
add
we will create a note tail
equals to head
while
next
is not null
this loop is enabling us to reach to the
tail node so that we can traverse it
from backside
now
while loop
until tail
is not equals to
head
layout
data
then
goes to
tail
prep
here
data
handle
this last c out statement is only
because we are not traversing till the
head pointer
now let's go to the main block
let's start with an empty list
node star
head
equals to
null
now let us create a linked list to test
the function
so we will use push function
another push function
ampersand head
comma three
since we are inserting at the beginning
so the actual linked list looks like
7
5
3
now
we will print the order linked list
first
see how
original
traverse
and
seals
reverse traversal
first traversed
linked list
and then
now let's try and execute this program
as you can see we have traversed it in
the
normal way as well as the reversed way
let's get back to our slides
next up insertion at the beginning
we will create a node with the previous
pointer pointing to a null and the next
pointer pointing to the head node
then we will change the head node's
previous pointer to the new node and we
will change the new node to the head
node
next up insertion at the end
we have to give the new node's address
to the last node's next pointer and
change the new node's previous pointer
to the last node
next up insertion at a specific position
we will change the previous node's next
pointer to the new node and the new
node's previous pointer to the previous
node and the next pointer to the next
node and vice versa
now let's try these operations in a code
editor
we will start by creating a class
node
public
pointer
now we will write a function push
insert a note at the beginning of the
list
its argument is note pointer to pointer
head
into new data
we will first allocate a new node
note star
new node
equals new
node parenthesis
now we will put in the data
node
arrow
data
is equals to new data
now we will make the next of the new
node as head
and previous as null
and new node
previous
is equals to null
now we will change the previous of the
head node to the new node
first we will check if the head node is
null
then
star head
previous
is equals to
new node
now i will move the head to the point to
the new node
now let's write another function to
insert a node after a specific position
void
insert after
its argument will be
node
data
if we first check if the given previous
node is null
yes then we will give it c out
given node
we will return to the function
or else we will allocate a new node
let's do new
now we will put in the data
now we will make the next of the new
node as the next of the previous node
equals to
ref
node
now i will make the next of the prep
node as new node
and make the prev node as the previous
of the new node
now i will change the previous of the
new node's next node
if
new node
next
is not null
then
new node
next
rev
is equals to new node
now let's write another function
insert a node at the end of the list
void
append
its argument will be
a node pointer to pointer
head
new data
first we will allocate a new node
equals to
new
parenthesis
now we will create another node last
equals to head
now
we will put in the data
node data
equals to new data
now since this new node will be the last
node so its next will be null
and
is equal to equation
null
and
star head
equals to new node
return
or else we will traverse till the last
node
file
last
next
is not null
last
equals to
last next
now we will make the last node as the
previous of the new node
return
now we will write a print list function
to print this list
the argument is
a node pointer node
while
node
is not null
data
or is equals to node
next
now
let's write the main block
we will start with an empty list
we will start by inserting six so the
link list becomes 6 null
and
ampersand
head
how much six
now we will insert seven at the
beginning
push
percent head
comma seven
now we will insert one at the beginning
also
now we will insert four at the end
till now the link list looks like
one
seven
six
four
now we will insert 8 after 7
so insert
after
head
next
comma
eight
now
let's print
this linked list
let's try and execute this
as you can see we have created our
linked list in the correct order
let's get back to our slide
next up deletion
first up deletion at the beginning
we have to change the first nodes next
to null and second nodes previous to
null
next up deletion at the end
we have to change the second last node
next pointer to null and delete the
previous node to free up the space
next up deletion at a specific position
we will change the previous node's next
pointer to the next node
and next node's previous pointer to the
previous node
now let's try these operations in a code
editor
we will start by creating a class node
click
data
node pointer
next
load pointer
now we will write a function to delete a
node in a doubly linked list
void
delete
node
its argument as pointer to the head
repeat its argument as pointer to the
head node pointer
and pointer the node to be deleted
now we will check the base case
condition
that is if
add
is
or
not to be deleted is null
and return
now
if
the node to be deleted is a head node
then
added
is equals to
now
if
next node of the dell
partner
that is
if
the node to be dedicated is not the last
node
then
else next
previous
equals to
else
previous
now we will change prev only if not to
be related is not the first node
so if
not equals to
null
then
next
equals to
del's next
finally
we will free the memory occupied by the
dell
free
and
now let's write a function to insert a
node at the beginning of the wlink list
void
contour to the head node pointer
and enter new data
we will allocate the node
now we will put in the data
since we are adding at the beginning so
prev is always null
now we will link the old list of the new
node
now we will change the preview of the
head node to the new node
now we will move the head to the point
to the new node
now let's write print list function
note pointer node
while
node
is not equals to null
c out
data
load
goes to node
next
now let's get started with the main
block
we will start with the empty list
now we will create new nodes
push
percent head
comma
2 push
ampersand
add
comma 4
push ampersand
head
comma 6
push
10 percent head
comma 8
now let's print this list
see out
original list
original list
we will call the printlist function
now we will delete the node from the
doubly linked list
here we are deleting the first node
next let's delete the last node
now the modified list
should look like
4
8.
let's try and print this
c out
defined
list
let's try and execute this
as you can see we have deleted all the
nodes except for 6 and 4.
let's get back to our slides
at last let's sum up what we have
learned in this session
first up we have recognized doubly
linked list as dynamic data structures
next the w link list offers faster
insertion and deletion operation
next up doubly linked lists are
bi-directional linked list
that is we can traverse it in both
direction
finally a doubly linked list is faster
at reverse traversal let's get started
with introduction to circular linked
list
a circular linked list is a linear data
structure made up of nodes
it is like a single linked list except
its last node points at the head node
these nodes consist of two parts data
and reference to next pointer these
nodes can be traversed using the next
pointer
now let's try to implement it in the
code editor we will start by creating
nodes
to create a node we need a class
node
we will define its members as public
link to data
and node pointer
next
now let's write a function to insert a
node at the beginning
void push
we will use arguments as a pointer to
node pointer head
and enter data
we will define a node
new node
equals to new
note parenthesis
star head
now we will put in the data into a new
node
since we are inserting at the beginning
of the linked list that's why this new
nodes next should be the head pointer
if linked list is not null then
set the next of the last node as head
while
next
is not equals to
head
the temp
is equals to
temp
arrow next
now
then
next
is equals to new node
else
new node
is next to
new node
star head
equals to newnode
now let's write a function to print this
linked list
void
list
node
star head
node
star temp
is equals to head
if
add
is not equals to
null
then
do
see out
temp
data
now while
amp
is not equals to
head
this condition is important to stop this
loop so that it doesn't go infinitely
now let's go to the main block
let's initialize this list as empty
node
star head
equals to null
now let's insert some nodes in this
linked list
push
amp percent head
comma
to
push
ampersand
push
ampersand head
comma 11
head
now this linked list looks like
5
11.
nine
two
then it will again go back to five
now let's try to print this
see out
circular
listed
now let's try and execute this
as you can see we have successfully
created our first circular linked list
let's get back to our slide we have now
introduced the circular linked list now
let's discuss some of the operations we
can apply on a circular linked list
we can perform two operations on a
circular linked list
first up insertion
we can perform insertion at three
different situation
at the beginning at the last and at a
specific position after a node
next up deletion we can perform deletion
at the three different situations
first up at the beginning at the last
and at a specific position after a node
let's discuss these in detail first up
insertion at the beginning
we have to give the first notes address
to the new node's next pointer to
execute this
next up insertion at the end
we have to give new nodes address to the
last node's reference pointer
next up insertion at a specific position
we will change the previous node's
reference address to the new node's
address and the new nodes reference
pointer to the next node's address
now let's try these operations in a code
editor
so far we have implemented a linked list
using classes
now let's try to implement it using
structures
we will start by creating a struct
node
with its element as int
data and struct
node
next
now we will write a function which can
only insert a node to empty list
struct
node
star
add
empty
star
last
comma
end new data
now since this function is only for the
empty list so we will have to check if
the link list is empty or not
if
last
is not equals to
null
then we will return last
now let's create a node dynamically
struct
node
start temp
equals to
struct
node
star
malloc
size of
we will copy this statement because we
will need it in the future functions
we will assign the data to this new node
temp
data
is equals to
neutral
data
last
is equals to temp
now we will create the link to that we
will use last
next
is equals to last
since we are in an empty list so the
first node will always point to itself
return
start
node
star
we are creating a function to insert at
the beginning of the linked list
struct
node
star
add
again
this argument we will use struct
node
last
comma
and
data
if
last
is equals to null
then we will return
empty
last
comma data
now we will create a node
dynamically
i have already copied this statement for
the ease
now we will put in the data
data
is equal to data
temp
next
is equals to
last
next
last
next
is equals to
return
last
now we will write a function to insert a
node at the end
start
node
star
last
data
if
last
equals to equals to null
and
return
add empty
last comma data
now we will dynamically create a node
and put in the data
temp
data
equals to
next
is equals to
last
next
now last next
equals to
temp
and last equals to
return
now we will write a function to insert a
node after a specific node
so struct
node
star
add after
start
node
star
this item is a node after which we have
to insert the node
if
last
equals to equational
then
return
structure
p
e
is equals to
last
next
now do
[Music]
if
equals to
we will dynamically create a node here
temp
is equals to
structure
load
star
lock
size of
now we will put in the data so temp
data
is equals to data
temp
next
is equals to
next
a p next
is equals to
temp
if
e is equals to last
last
is equals to temp
return
equals to
next
while
e
is not equal to
last
text
see out
item
not
present
in the list
return
last
now we will write a function to print
this list
void
print
list
struct
node
start lost
now if
last is equals to null
then
c out
list
is empty
and return
else
we will point to the first node of the
list
so p is equals to
last
next
to traverse the list we will use do
while loop
so do
c out
next
while
e
is not equals to
last
text
now
let's write a code for the main block
we will start with an empty list
struct
node
star
last
supposed to
none
now last
is equals to
add
empty
last comma
six
last equals to
add begin
comma
4
last
equals to
add
begin
last
comma two
last
equals to
add
and
last
comma
12.
last
equals to
add
after
last
comma
10
comma
4.
list
let's execute this
as you can see we have created the
linked list in the correct order
let's get back to our slides
now let's talk about deletion
first up deletion at the beginning
we have to change the first node's
address to the null to execute this
next up deletion at the end
we have to change the second last node's
address to null to execute this
next up
deletion at a specific position
we will change the previous node's
reference address to the next node's
address
now let's try these operations in the
code editor
let's get started with creating a node
to create a node we need a class node
we will declare its members as public
and data
node pointer
next
now we will write a function to insert a
node at the beginning of the list
void
push
a pointer to the node pointer header
and new data
now let's create a node and make head as
next of it
load
star
node
equals to
new
node parenthesis
let's put in the data
new
node
data
is equals to new data
and
new node
next
is equals to
head
if linked list is not null then set the
next of the last node
as the first
node if
star head
is not null
then they will find the node before head
and update next to it
so node star
temp
is equals to star head
while
and next
is not
equals to head
is equals to
tamp
next
now temp
next
equals to
new node
else
new node
next
is equals to
new node
and star head
is equals to
new node
now let's write a function to delete a
given node from the list
so
void
delete
node
its argument is a pointer to the node
pointer
add
and
end key
now if linked list is empty then we will
simply return it
if
star head
is equal to
null
then return
otherwise
if
and
add
next
is equals to head
then
free
add
is equal to null
return
now
node
last
is equals to
star head
comma star d
now if head is to be deleted
then
star head
data
is equals to
key
then
while
next
not equals to
star head
then last
is equals to last next
now we will point the last node to the
second node of the list
now we will free this head
our head
equals to
last
next
now if either the node to be deleted is
not found or the end of the list is not
reached
then
while
last
next
is not equals
to head
and
last
next
data is not equal to key
then
last equals to
last
if note to be deleted was found
then
if
last
next
data
is equals to key
then
d is equals to
last
next
and
last
next
is equals to
d is next
now we will free
d
or else
see
out
no
such
key
found
you
now let's write a function to print this
list
void
print list
node star
head
node
star
temp
is equals to
head
if
head
is not null
do
c out
temp
data
amp
is equals to
next
while
temp
is not equals to head
see out
now let's write a code for the main
block
we will start by empty list
so note star
head
equals to
null
now we will
push ampersand head
push
ampersand head
comma
5
push
ampersand head
comma
seven
push
ampersand
head comma
8
and push
ampersand head comma 10
now we will print the list before any
deletion operation
c out
list
before
deletion
list
head
now let's delete
ampersand
add
let's delete seven
see out
list
after deletion
print list
let's execute this
as you can see our deletion function is
working perfectly
let's get back to our slides
at last let's sum up what we have learnt
in this session
first up we have recognized circular
linked list as dynamic data structures
next the circular linked lists offer
faster insertion and deletion operation
next a circular linked list are
unidirectional in nature
that is we can only traverse it in one
direction
finally a circular linked list traversal
is quite tricky as we have to stop the
loop as soon as we revisit the first
node
otherwise it will traverse it
indefinitely
so at first what exactly is an array so
an array is a linear data structure that
stores homogeneous data elements in a
continuous form
so homogeneous in the sense you will be
able to store only one single data type
of elements in an array for example
consider that you have declared an array
and you wanted to store some elements in
the array so you can declare a data type
first after that the name of the array
and if you declared that the array
should store in teacher data type then
you can only store integer elements in
that particular data type you cannot
store any other data type like float or
character that is the meaning of this
particular definition and it stores the
elements in a continuous order that is
in the adjacent format as you can see in
the example here 10 20 30 40 and which
are located in the adjacent locations
that is 0 1 2 and 3. now let us
understand what exactly is a linked list
so similar to array even a linked list
is a linear data structure but the only
difference is it is a dynamic data
structure here you can increase or
decrease the size of the linked list in
run time
the only difference is here the memory
locations are not adjacent to each other
but they are taken from the memory heap
so there is a huge memory chunk out of
that the linked list will borrow some of
the memory locations and one after the
other the memory nodes will be
interconnected using pointers
so that was the difference between array
and linked list and similar to arrays
even the linked list store homogeneous
type of elements that is if you declare
a linked list of float data type then
you can only store float data type in it
you cannot store any other different
data type like character or string
now followed by that let us understand
the types of arrays
so basically we have three different
types of arrays those are the
one-dimensional arrays and inside
multi-dimensional arrays we find two
more types those are the two dimensional
arrays and three dimensional arrays now
one dimensional arrays will be having
only one subscript that is where they'll
be having only one single row whereas in
the two dimensional arrays we will be
having two subscripts that is it will be
having rows and columns
and in the three dimensional arrays it
will be having three subscripts that is
the row column and the block address now
followed by the types of arrays we will
understand the types of linked lists
so similar to arrays even linked lists
are divided into three types they are
singly linked list doubly linked list
and circular linked list the difference
between them is a singly linked list
will have two parts that is the node
address and node element in this
particular segment the element will be
stored and in this particular second
segment the address that points to the
next node will be saved and similarly in
the circular linked list the only
difference between the singly linked
list and the circular linked list is at
the end of the single learning list we
can see a null pointer which indicates
the end of the linked list but in
circular linked list the address will
not be null instead it will point back
to the head node that is what which
makes it as a circular type dissingly
linked list or a circular linked list
when it comes to the third type that is
the doubly linked list we can see there
are two address locations the first
starting node will have null as its
first address location then we'll store
the element and the second address
location will point to the next node and
you can see in the second node will have
element and the first address location
will point to the previous node and the
second address location will point to
the next node and at the end the second
address location will be pointed as null
which indicates as the
end of the linked list
now that we know the types of linked
lists and arrays we will look into the
fundamental differences between arrays
and linked lists
so the first fundamental differences
between the arrays and linked list is
the array element can be accessed
randomly using just the index values but
whereas random access is not possible in
linked list if you want to access any
element in linked list you need to
perform the traverse operation
sequentially
the second difference between the both
is
array is static which means memory size
is fixed which cannot be changed in
runtime but whereas in the linked list
the memory is dynamic which means you
can either shrink or expand the memory
in runtime according to your
requirements
followed by that the next difference is
each element in array is independent in
nature that is you can access any
element just by giving the index
location whereas in linked list the
elements are interdependent on each
other whenever you want to access a
specific element you need to go through
the other elements or traverse through
the other elements
next one is the array takes more time in
operations like insertion and deletion
whereas linked list takes less time to
perform the operations of insertion and
deletion followed by that the next
difference is accessing any element is
faster in array as random access as
possible and the array data structure
just by using its index values but
whereas accessing an element in linked
list is slow because we know that we
need to traverse through all the node
elements to access a particular element
now the next difference is in case of an
array memory allocation is done in
compile time whereas in linked list the
memory allocation is done during the run
time
memory utilization is inefficient in an
array as it is allocated as in static
and it is allocated during the compile
time in case of linked list the memory
utilization is very efficient as the
memory is allocated during the runtime
what is a stack
so basically stack is a linear data
structure just like arrays and linked
lists the only difference is that it
follows a specific order when an
operation is implemented on it so what
is the specific order that it follows
that is lifo last in first out or failo
first in last out in the next part we
will understand this order in a much
better way
all operations can be done only at the
one end of the stack that is on the top
now we will discuss much about that in
the operations part of the stack now let
us understand the first fundamental that
is the representation of stack that is
how do you represent a stack normally
so a stack can be represented using two
different methods that is using an array
or using a linked list so in an array we
will be using the continuous memory
and in stack we will be using a
non-continuous memory and the stack will
behave like a dynamic stack or a dynamic
data structure
now the first method that is the array
method
so in this method an array is used to
represent the stack as you can see in
the image below we have a stack
so the name of the stack is stack itself
and you can see two more things here
that is top is equals to 2 and max is 4.
so the max is the value of the array or
the length of the array the maximum
length of the array and top is the
position where the last element of the
stack is present here in this case 56 is
the last element in the stack and top is
inclined or it is addressing to that
particular address that is two
and now let us discuss about the linked
list representation of stack
so in this method a dynamic data
structure that is a linked list is used
to represent the stack
this representation leads to a dynamic
stack it does not need to define the
maximum number of elements present in
the stack remember in arrays we had to
define the max value in the previous
example we had the max value as 5 but in
here you need not to assign the max
value as the stack itself is dynamic
the pointers links are used to store the
address of the upcoming nodes and the
variable used in this method is top so
the top is holding the address of the
topmost element in the linked list
representing the stack
now moving ahead we shall understand the
basic operations on stack now here we
will understand the previously discussed
definition that is push pull etc in a
much better way so the basic operations
on a stack are push
pop or pull and peek
now let us discuss each one of them in a
detailed way the first one is push
operation
so the push operation is the mechanism
of inserting a new element into the
stack
as you can see we are trying to insert
the elements from the top so the push
operation basically involves the
following steps check if the stack is
either full or not so basically whenever
you are trying to insert an element into
the stack you need to make sure that the
stack is empty or it has some space if
it is full you cannot insert an element
into the stack step two if the stack is
full produce an error and exit that's
what i was talking about now the step
three
if the stack is not full increment the
top by one that is when you're inserting
an element then you need to update the
top value for example in the previous
slide when we had the array
representation of a stack we had the top
value as 2. so if you try to include an
element into the stack then you need to
update the top value from 2 to 3 that is
incremented by 1.
now the fourth step add data elements to
the stack where the top is pointing
and finally success the push operation
has been successful so this is how you
insert or push an element into the stack
now followed by push operation we have
pop or pull
so the pop operation is a mechanism of
eliminating or deleting or removing one
data element from the existing stack
so we shall understand the
pop operation in a much more detailed
way the operation involves checking the
stack is empty or not if in case the
stack is not empty then you can carry
forward the pop operation but in case if
the stack is empty then you have to
provide an exit status and exit the
control and leave the stack
so if the stack is not empty approach
the data element at the top that is at
the top position for example in the
previous array example remember right we
had the top position pointing towards
two so you need to take the control to
the top position and pick out the
element and pop it
and finally decrease the top by one so
when you eliminate the top element then
the top value from 2 will be decremented
to 1.
so this is how the pop operation is
carried over on a stack
next one is
the peak operation
the peak operation involves returning
the topmost data element from the stack
without moving it
so here you can see the top is pointing
to the element number four
and you're picking the
element number four and you're not
removing it from the stack you're just
returning the top most data element
you're passing the value of the top
element
so to understand the push pop and peak
operations on stack in a much more
better way let's carry out a practical
example
now we are on the practical mode and
here you can see on my screen we have
the code example for the stack
now first we'll be checking if the stack
is empty as per the steps mentioned in
the previous discussion we will check if
the stack is empty or not if it is empty
then we will return else we will
continue and again another step we also
check if the stack is full if the stack
is full we will exit else we will
continue with the operation whatever it
is peak pop or push and here we have an
example for the peak operation that we
discussed previously and followed by
that we have a pop operation we are
trying to exclude an element from the
stack
and another one we have the push
operation where we'll be trying to push
the elements into the stack so these are
the three functions for push pop and
peak now we'll try to push in the
elements and also pop and try to involve
some functions on it or run some
operations on the stack now let's run
this code and see the output
so you can see that the code has
successfully executed and we have the
statements here the first one says the
stack is not full that is false and
stack is empty that is true
right and after that you can see that
the elements which we try to push into
the stack that is 11 76 71 15 and 66 are
been pushed into the stack and if you
clearly observe it we have the element
11 in the bottom 76 upon that 71 upon
that and 15 and last 66 so the order is
first in
last out that is the first element was
pushed first and when you are trying to
eliminate the elements from the stack
then you will first pick out 66 followed
by that you will pick out 15 followed by
that you will pick out 71 and so on so
this is the rule what stack follows
now i hope i made myself clear with the
example now we shall continue with the
applications of stack
so these are the few applications of
stack the first one is expression
conversion
so you can see we have the in fixed
notation prefix notation and postfix
notation so the infix notation is no
rocket science there is only one thing
here to learn that is we have two
operands a and b and we have one
operator that is the addition operator
in between those two operands
and when you use the prefix notation you
will have the operator located at the
first place then you will have the
operands followed by it
and in the postfix one you will have the
operands first and followed by the
operands you will have the operator
so basically all the infects prefix and
postfix notations give out the same
results but the only difference is the
representation of those operands and
operators
now let us understand this in a much
more detailed way
so conversion of expression from one
form to another form is
the main application of stack so we have
the first one that is in fix to prefix
and infix to postfix now let us see an
example here you have 1 plus 2 star 3
plus 4 so this is the normal infix
notation and when you
try to present the same expression in
the form of prefix notation so this will
be the result and this is the result for
postfix
the next one prefix to postfix and
prefix to infix
and this is the way you write the prefix
notation and if you want to convert that
to infix this is how you can write it
and this happens to be the result of
postfix notation
and finally postfix to prefix postfix to
infix and these are the results
now followed by expression evaluation
the next important
application of
stack is checking parenthesis
and you can see if the parenthesis is
set properly the expression gets
evaluated if not it will not be
evaluated
now the last one memory management and
function call the very useful thing of
using a stack is
the memory will not be allocated to your
stack elements unless the function is
called here you can see it is the main
function and these are the elements that
you wanted to declare into your stack
and unless you make a function call the
elements will not be declared their
memory or the elements will not get the
memory allocated for them
now another good application of stack as
the backtracking problem or the end
queen problem
the end queen problem is an example of
backtracking problem the end queen's
solution to this problem is to position
the queen in such a way that the
opponent queen cannot attack your queen
now another example is string reversal
you can see on my screen we have a
string that is a b c d and e now using
stacks you can reverse this
right so you're basically eliminating an
element and relocating it to the first
place
and finally after reversing your string
this will be your result a b c d and e
followed by that we have conversion
evaluation
so stack is used to evaluating the
expression as shown in the example
since parenthesis has the highest
precedence 5 plus 4 gets evaluated first
and it will result in 9
then multiplication and division have
the same precedence
now the associativity comes into picture
so the associativity is always from left
to right so first
4 into 9 will be executed which will
result in 36 and then 32 divided by 4
which will give us 8.
now we have 36 minus 8 which will give
us an answer that is 26.
now the last application is the tower of
hanoi so the tower of hanoi is a
mathematical puzzle consisting of three
rods and n discs
this puzzle consists of some rules
the first rule states that
one disk can move only at a time the
second rule is that the disk can only be
moved when it is at the uppermost
position on the stack
the third one no dusk is allowed to
place on the top of the smaller disk
so this is how the tower of hanoi works
so first up what exactly is a linked
list so linked list is a dynamic data
structure it allocates memory
dynamically the nodes are maintained in
a non-continuous memory that is in
linked list we have nodes so each and
every node is connected via a pointer
which points to the address of the next
node
each node contains next pointer that is
the next pointers address which keeps
the reference to the next node and it
also has another section which stores
the data the top most note always
contains null in its address
and this is how a linked list looks like
so this is the top which is the
beginning position of the linked list
and this is the address of the first
location and this is the next node this
is the following node then this is the
last node and this points back to the
head node so this is how you can
implement a stack like data structure
using linked list you can see that we
can perform stack like operation that is
the elements are located one above the
other and the top is pointing to the
head node
now let us go through the implementation
of stack using linked list first we will
go through traversing of stack using
linked list
so displaying each node of the linked
list representing stack is termed as
traversing copy the head pointer to the
temporary pointer and then move
temporary node through all the nodes and
display values of each node
so you can see the animation here will
explain you how the traversal goes
through the linked list in real time
now another linked list implementation
of stack is the push operation
so adding a new node to the top of the
stack is termed as push operation
generally in stack we have three
operations that is push pop and peak so
one of the operation is push where you
add an element into the stack in the
same way using linked list you can add a
new node to the stack and point it as
the top of the stack or the first
element which represents the top in
terms of stack
now create a node first and allocate a
new memory to it if the list is empty
and node consists of data and null is
the address it will be inserted as the
first node if there is some node already
existing
then add a new node at the beginning to
avoid violations
so the following animation will help you
understand how we add a new element or
the top element to the stack using
linked lists
now followed by the push operation we
have the pop operation
so now let us go through the pop
operation
removing a node from the top of the
stack is termed as pop operation
in the same way we will be eliminating
the first node from the linked list
which is termed as top
underflow condition may occur when you
try to remove the node if the stack is
already empty
in stack node can be removed from one
end only therefore the value stored in
the head pointer must be deleted and the
node must be freed
followed by the pop operation we have
the peak operation
retrieving the topmost node of the
linked list representing stack without
removing the linked list node from the
top of the stack is termed as peak
operation generally when you're using a
stack data structure just retrieving the
value of the top node is called as peak
operation you're not going to eliminate
or you're not going to add a new element
to the top you're just going to copy the
element or you're just going to retrieve
the element which is pointed as top this
operation is called as peak
now in the linked list you can also
perform this operation of peak
now with the theory discussed let us
execute a practical program based on
stack implementation using linked list
now on my screen you can see a code
example using which we will implement
stack using a linked list now here we
have the pop operation push operation
and top and then the main function
don't worry about the code this
particular code snippet will be attached
in the description box below or you can
also request us and we will have it sent
to your mail id and you can understand
the code and try executing in your local
system now without further ado let's
directly run the code
so there you go the code got
successfully compiled and we have tried
to add some elements into the stack that
is a b c
and c is being the top most element of
the stack and that element has got
popped and followed by that the element
on the top currently after c being
popped out is b and the node element b
got popped again and the only element
which was present in the stack is a and
that element is also popped out after
performing the pop operation and now
currently the stack is empty you can see
that we have tried to push the elements
a b c and also we try to pop the
elements a b c
let's get started with introduction to q
you know that all of us depend on
messaging applications like whatsapp
facebook messenger instagram chats to
communicate with our friends and family
members and while using them you must
have observed that the person you are
trying to communicate with receives
messages in the same order as you have
sent them now the question that arises
here is how is this happening how are
these applications maintaining the order
of these text messages
and the solution to these questions
bring us to queue
basically in these applications a queue
is maintained for each user containing
the messages to be delivered to the user
when the user connects to the network
all the text messages in the queue gets
delivered and once the messages are
delivered empty queues get deleted
this example clearly illustrates the
importance of data structures so let's
dive further and understand the
structure of the queue in depth
but before doing that let's look at a
real-life example of cues to understand
it more clearly
the most common and relevant example of
a queue is a movie ticket counter
in the movie ticket counter you must
have observed that both of its ends
remain open also these ends are fixed
with the help of barricades and that is
why no one can enter in between these
ticket lines
additionally the person who enters first
receives a ticket first and the person
who enters last will obviously get
served at last
cues and data structure resembles all
these properties of a movie ticket
counter which makes them better at
creating virtual first-come first-served
systems
basically they are defined as a linear
collection of different data types that
allow insertion at one end and deletion
at another
unlike any other data structure the q
ends remain open allowing it to have
different functionalities at both ends
the end at which insertion takes place
is called rare
and the end at which deletion takes
place is known as front
furthermore there are two approaches to
consider the structure of the queue and
both of them depend on the approach of
the programmer
that means being a programmer if you
consider the left hand as front then
your rear node will be at right end
otherwise if you consider the left hand
as rare then the right end will be your
q's front node
unlike arrays and linked lists elements
in the queue cannot be operated from
their respective locations here they can
only be operated from the front or rare
position
moving on let's discuss the operations
in queue data structures one by one
the first operation is enqueue it is
used to store the elements in the queue
next up is dq this operation is used for
removing them
further we have isful and is null
operations is full function scrutinizes
if the queue is full or not and the is
null operation evaluates if the queue is
empty
we also have a peak operation that helps
you get the element from the front of
the queue without removing it
let's now understand how these
operations work with the help of the
following examples
here we will look at nq5 and q1 and q
minus 2 then is full
then dq
peak
and is null
but before explaining these operations
it's essential that we initialize the
queue data structure by assigning some
random size to it
for example end queue of three by this
declaration we are assigning only three
spaces for insertion and queue
also at this phase there is no element
in the queue as its empty so both the
front node and rear node will point to
the same location with null memory space
in the storage system let's consider
that null index to be -1 for ease of our
convention
now the first operation on our list is
nq of 5.
as we discussed previously enqueue
operation is nothing but the insertion
of data into a queue data structure
it begins with checking if the queue is
full or not
if the queue is full then the previously
assigned memory is completely filled
with data elements
so insertion would not be possible this
is also known as overflow error in terms
of programming
but as our queue is empty so the
insertion can be performed here for that
we have to increment the rare pointer to
index 0 from index -1
and once we do that the data element phi
will be added to the queue also for
front insertion both front and rear will
point to the same location as there is
only one element present in this queue
let's insert two more elements into this
queue with the operations nq1 and q
minus 2.
for that we have to increment the rare
pointer to the next index which will be
1.
now as the point is incremented so the
data will be entered into this position
next up is nq minus 2. again we have to
follow the same process of incrementing
the rare pointer we will increment the
rare pointer to point towards the next
index that is index 2 and hence the data
element with value -2 will be entered
here
the next operation on our list is is
full
in this operation if the rare pointer
points to the max size then the queue is
considered to be full as there is no
space left for insertion in our case the
max size of rq is 12 bytes
additionally we are considering to enter
only three integer elements
and one integer data element takes four
bytes of the memory space that means
three integer elements will take 12
bytes hence this function will prompt q
is full on the screen
now we will discuss the dq operation if
we want to access data from a queue we
have to perform two sub tasks the first
one is access the data where the front
is pointing and another is to remove the
data after access and this complete
process is called as dq operation
the first step of this operation is to
check if the queue is empty
if the queue is empty then there is no
element available for deletion this is a
case of underflow error
but as our queue is not empty we can
proceed with the next steps we will be
accessing data from the front node and
later we will be incrementing the front
pointer in order to remove the link to
the previous node so that the data gets
removed now front will point to the
index 1.
thus the data value 5 will be removed
from the queue and will also be prompted
on the screen
therefore this function comes with an
integer return type
next up is peak operation
in this operation element at the front
node will be accessed without deleting
it
the algorithm for this operation begins
with checking if the queue is empty or
not
if the queue is not empty then data at
the front node will be accessed with
temporary variable and printed on the
screen
advancing further let's perform two more
dequeue operations here first is dq of
one and another one is dq of minus two
the data at a front node will be
accessed primarily and the front pointer
will be incremented to point to the next
data element
when we do the point incrementation the
link to the previous node gets removed
which results in data deletion
similarly we will perform a dq of -2
operation here now the front will be
pointed to null memory space as there is
no element left in rq and the data -2
will be removed
the last operation on our list is is
empty
this function checks if the queue is
empty or not in the previous procedure
we mentioned that if the front points to
the null memory space then the queue is
empty and in our case the front is
already pointing to -1
so the output of this function will be q
is empty
this is all about operations in the
queue i hope that you all are clear with
these operations
next we will discuss different types of
queues and their structures at a glance
basically there are four types of queues
linear queue circular queue
priority queue and double ended queue
the structure which we have discussed
till this time is that of a linear queue
so now we will move on to circular queue
the circular queue is almost similar to
the linear queue except that the last
node of this queue is connected to the
first
it is also known as ring buffer as all
the ends are connected to another end
additionally this circular queue is a
better version of the linear queue as it
removes the drawback of insertion in the
linear queue
the empty space available in a circular
queue can be filled with the new element
by simply incrementing the value of the
rare position we will learn about this
in detail in our further sessions
a priority queue is another special type
of queue data structure in which each
element has some priority assigned with
it
based on the priority of each element
the elements are arranged in a priority
queue if the elements occur with the
same priority then they are served
according to the first in first out
principle
in the priority queue the insertion
occurs based on the arrival while the
deletion occurs based on the priority
the above figure shows that the highest
priority element comes first and the
elements of the same priority are
arranged based on the first in first out
structure
the last type of queue is dq
dq is a linear data structure in which
the insertion and deletion operations
are performed from both the ends we can
say that dq is a generalized version of
the queue
dq can be used as stack as well as q as
it allows the insertion and deletion
operations on both the ends
if the insertion takes place at one end
and deletion at another then that eq is
known as a linear queue
and if both addition and deletion are
performed at a single end then that eq
is called stack
advancing further let's discuss some
applications of queues to gauge an
insight into the importance of queues
the queue data structure is used in
computers printers and applications to
utilize the benefits of the first come
first serve technique
in computers whenever you work on
documents or ppt you must have observed
that whichever key you press on the
keyboard appears in the exact same order
on the screen
but when your processor is too busy with
other tasks you might notice that the
keys you press appear on the screen with
some delay after you press them
basically those keys are stored in queue
and when the processor becomes free it
processes in the order the keys are
pressed
that means the key pressed first will be
written in a word document first
so this is how computers use a queue to
eliminate deadlocks when multiple
processes are in a ready state
next up is printers
a queue data structure is used in
printers to maintain the order of pages
while printing that means the pages are
stored in a queue in the order that you
want to print them and once the page is
removed from an ordered queue it gets
printed
another most common application of queue
data structure is their usage in web or
mobile apps
applications like domino swigi uses a
queue for maintaining food order status
if you place an order from an online
portal your order id enters the queue
and once the previous orders before your
order id gets scattered then your order
will be catered as well
from these examples we can clearly say
that queues are used whenever there is a
need for an fcfs strategy in software
development so whenever you work on
projects that need a first come first
approach then remember that you have to
implement a queue data structure to
complete it successfully
finally let's have a look at some key
takeaways that we discussed in this
session
we started this session by examining the
structure of the queue
we learned that the queue is a linear
data structure
after that we talked about different
operations of queues in which we learnt
nq and dq are responsible for data
manipulation in a queue
later we discussed different types of
queues as well
finally we discovered some applications
of queues and how they fulfill the need
of fcfs systems
we have also made it clear that queues
can handle multiple data types as well
a queue is a linear collection of
different data types that allow
insertion at one end and deletion at
another unlike any other data structure
the queue ends remain open allowing it
to have different functionalities at
both ends
additionally the queue works with the
restriction that insertion should be
performed at the rear node and deletion
at a front node
those processes of insertion and
deletion are called nq and dq
respectively we discovered both of these
operations along with three more
supportive procedures named as peak is
full and is null
now that we are considering to implement
a queue data structure so all these
operations will become different
functional blocks additionally all these
operations must take constant time and
it must not depend upon a variable like
the number of elements in q or the size
of the queue by that what i mean is the
complexity of all these operations must
be o of one
having said that let's dive deep into
the strategy to implement q data
structure until now we have understood
that q is a special kind of list with
some restrictions on insertion and
deletion and there are two approaches to
deal with queue implementation the first
one is array based and another one is
linked list based in this session we are
going to focus on array based
implementation
initially let's say we want to create a
queue of integer elements for that
purpose firstly it is essential to
declare an array of random spaces let's
take hundred as the size of our rra that
means our array can have a maximum of
hundred integer elements the declaration
of an array is made with this line of
code intq hundred
where int represents integer data type
and q is the name of our array and
hundred is its size
the array that we just initialized is
going to store our queue
by that what i mean is that any random
index of an array queue is going to
start with two marked ends front and
rear
in this array i am showing front of the
cue towards the left and rear towards
the right
for making those end nodes we need to
initialize two pointers front and rear
at this moment as our queue is empty so
both of those pointers should point
towards -1 so initialization of these
pointers should be done as inch front is
equal to -1 and inter is equal to -1
when the insertion or deletion happens
in queues these pointers will be either
incremented or decremented so they are
an essential part of this queue
implementation process
now you must be clear with the array and
pointers declaration part so let's dive
further and formulate code for queue
implementation using a one dimensional
array in c plus plus
it is essential to include header files
into our source file as we cannot access
standard c plus functionalities without
them
that is why here we are going to load io
stream and standard input output files
along with using namespace sdd
once this is done we will initialize our
array along with front and rear pointers
remember we always have to declare the
size of an array before compilation
that means we cannot update the size of
an array at runtime
this scenario is the biggest limitation
of queue implementation using arrays
having said that let's proceed with
pointers declaration
now we are done with the initialization
process we will now work on
implementation of queue functionalities
let's first work out supportive queue
functions like is null is full and peak
isn't function validates if the queue is
empty
and as per our previous discussion when
both front and rear points to -1 then
the queue is considered to be empty
so the condition to determine if q is
empty will be
if rare is equal to is equal to minus 1
and front is equal to is equal to minus
1 it will return q is empty
if the queue does not satisfy the
previous condition then it is not empty
so by using the else condition we can
display the queue is not empty
next up is is full function this
function validates if the queue is full
and we can clearly say that if the rare
pointer is equal to the max size of the
queue then our queue is going to be
completely full
next is peak
the peak function extracts the element
where the front pointer is pointing
without removing it from the queue
for this functionality to work our queue
must contain data elements in it
what i mean is our queue should not be
empty if our queue is not empty then
data at the front node can be accessed
this is how we implement supportive
queue functions let's immediately dive
into the development of main queue
operations nq and dq
for enqueue operation if the queue is
full then our function should prompt an
overflow error
for that to happen we have to put this
condition
if the front pointer is pointing to -1
then we have to increment the front
pointer to 0 manually
otherwise it can be incremented by rare
plus plus
after pointer incrementation we have to
ask for a data element to enter into the
queue
once the data is given it should be
inserted at the position where the rare
is pointing now
finally let's quote the final main queue
operation called as dq
if the queue is empty then there is no
element for deletion so it should prompt
an underflow error on screen
also if there is only one element left
inside q then both pointers should again
be pointed towards minus -1
for that let's write another condition
here
if both the previously mentioned
conditions are false then deletion of an
element can be achieved by just pointer
incrementation
foreign
we have implemented all the queue
functionalities here but we haven't
implemented a function that can show us
how our queue looks so for that let's
implement one more function with the
name display
this function should prompt the elements
of the queue on the screen
elements will only be printed if the
queue is not empty hence we have to
check for the emptiness of the cube
first
finally we are done with the hard part
so let's arrive at the main function to
contemplate these operations in order to
visualize outputs
we are going to use a switch case to
take a user command
thus not to waste your time on this let
me just get done with this block asap
that's all we are done with the queue
implementation using arrays let's just
examine if our code works fine or not by
compiling it
this program should return a console
that asks the user to give commands for
performing different operations
so as you can see on your screens if i
input 1 i can perform insertion in a
queue
let's perform some insertions now we
will insert 4 elements first 3
then 21
next 78
and finally 12.
after inserting these elements we will
print the state of the queue using case
3.
now let's also check the dq function
if we perform a dq operation then 3
should be remote from the queue
let's check if it is remote using the
display function
and yes our code works just fine
now if you're concerned about this code
then don't be as we can send it over to
you if you drop your email ids in the
comment section below
additionally you can also try to run it
on your local system to have a better
understanding of the concept
introduction to priority queue
primarily we will have a look at the
real life example of priority queue to
understand it better a hospital
emergency queue is almost an ideal
example of priority queue when you go to
the hospital you must have observed that
the person who needs immediate medical
attention will be treated first
irrespective of his arrival at the
reception that means treating a person
who is in agonizing pain or in emergency
medical condition is the priority of the
queue of patients
priority queue in computer science also
works with same approach so what exactly
is this priority queue
well a priority queue is an abstract
data type that operates similar to the
normal queue except for the fact every
element has certain priority assigned to
it
this definition of priority queue
suggests that this particular type of
queue also follows the same restrictions
for insertion and deletion of data
elements the insertion in the priority
queue will only be achieved at one end
and deletion at another or opposite time
additionally the priority of data
elements will determine the order of
removal the elements which have higher
priority will leave the queue at first
and the elements which has lower
priority will definitely leave the queue
at last
as a side note i would like to tell you
guys that the priority queue only
supports the elements that are
comparable
meaning the data that we are going to
insert into priority queue must be
orderable the compiler should not be
facing any difficulty while comparing
these data elements otherwise the
execution of a priority queue will
definitely fail moving ahead let's have
a look at an example of priority queue
in this priority queue we'll insert 7
to 45 23 and 12 respectively these
elements are not ordered so how the
priority queue is going to store them in
order
well at the time of insertion the
priority queue conducts a comparison of
each element with every other element
present inside a queue to store them in
order but as there is no element inside
a queue so the first insertion that is
an element with value 7 will be attained
followed by that the next element will
be inserted in a queue
since the newly inserted element is
smaller than that of previously inserted
element will swap their positions in
order to maintain order remember the
element with least value will have a
higher order and the element with
greatest value will have a least
priority or order
now we will insert the next element in a
queue that is 45. as fortifier is a
larger element than the elements inside
the queue there is no need to shuffle
elements when we make the next insertion
the element 32 will get inserted at
index 3. now this element is smaller
than that of 45 so the algorithm will
have to swap the locations of these 11.
now we will perform the final insertion
into our queue we will insert 12 at
index 4 now but as you can see this
element is smaller than both the
previous elements thus the algorithm
will have to swap their positions
now 45 will reach the end of q as it is
the element with highest value and 2
will remain at the front of q as it is
the least valued element
as a humans we could see the numbers
visually inside the priority queue and
further we can easily arrange them
but how does the machine know this does
it restore all the elements inside the
priority queue before each insertion no
obviously that would be highly
ineffective as there will be n
comparisons for insertion of n elements
leading to time complexity big o of n
square
this is an enormous time complexity
which we cannot allow in any software
application we will understand how the
priority queue manages to reduce this
time complexity in upcoming topics
but right now we will contemplate
different properties of a priority queue
that we have learned from previous
example the first property of priority
queue suggests that each element has a
certain priority assigned to it that
priority might depend on value of data
element it can be either larger or
smaller the next property states that
element with higher priority will leave
the queue at first where the element
with least priority will leave the
priority queue at last
further if two elements have the same
priority then the element will be
removed from the priority queue based on
their arrival that means the element
which arrived at first out of the
elements having same priority will be
removed first
now moving ahead we'll deal with the
representation of priority queue using a
linked list as usage of arrays is not an
ideal way to implement priority queue
if we consider array implementation of
priority queue then inserting items into
the sorted array will cost us big o of n
and in general processing each element
will further cost us big o of n square
as discussed previously so in this
tutorial we'll just look into the linked
list representation of priority queue
we will understand the representation of
priority queue with the help of an
example
initially let's say there are three
elements inside a link priority queue
and all of them are in order 3 being the
least element has highest priority where
43 has the least priority the purpose of
keeping three at the head node is that
we want our priority queue to delete
elements according to their priority
now we want to insert a new node
consisting of data element 2
and as the data element is smaller than
the element at head node that is 3 so
this new node should be inserted prior
to it
this particular scenario of insertion
seems pretty perfect but it does not
cost us more time but what if the
element is significantly larger than all
the nodes in queue for instance let's
say we want to insert 45 as a new
element
in that case primarily it will be
compared with element 2 and as 45 is
larger than 2 our temporary pointer will
move to the next node for comparison
now
45 will be compared with element 3 and
again the temporary pointer will be
moved to the next node for comparison
after two comparisons the temporary
pointer has reached element 17 for
performing the next comparison and here
also 45 is larger than 17 so the
temporary pointer will again move
towards the next node
now finally our temporary pointer has
arrived at the tail node consisting of
element 43 again in this case the
element 45 is larger than 43 thus the
new node will be inserted after node
containing data element 43.
from this specific example of insertion
into a priority queue we can clearly see
that there are n comparisons leading to
the time complexity big of n
where the complexity of deletion remains
constant that is bigger of 1.
while understanding the representation
of priority queue we came across some
packs that make priority queue
implementation using linked list quite
vulnerable
so here we will again try to recall them
the first drawback of priority queue
implementation using linked list is that
it cost us big o of n for inserting a
new element
further it also cost us big of n for
peak operation
and as memory and time management is the
purpose of data structure hence we must
try to analyze other implementation
strategies
that is why in upcoming slides we'll
look into different approaches to
implement the priority queue
there are three approaches that
implement a priority queue with
complexity less than big of n square we
have already discussed the linked list
so let's also look into other two
approaches
binary heap and binary tree provides
almost similar complexities these
approaches cost us big of log n for
insertion and deletion
and big of 1 for peak operation but
which one of these operation is most
optimal approach to implement priority
queue
well to answer this question we again
need to discuss about memory management
in the case of both this data structure
you guys know that binary heap data
structure is implemented using arrays
and since it utilizes arrays there is
always a better locality of reference as
well as operations become more cache
apprentices the binary search tree uses
pointer to implement front and rear node
which definitely takes up more space in
memory due to that building a cell
balancing bst cost us big o of n log n
where binary heap just cost us big o of
n
these facts clarify that the binary heap
is the best data structure to implement
a priority queue
now you must be thinking about what
exactly the heap is and how does it work
so moving forward we'll look into the
definition of heap and its properties
basically a heap is a tree based data
structure that satisfies the heap in
variant or in simpler words heap
property the heap invariant states that
if a is a parent node of b then a is
ordered with respect to b for all nodes
a and b in heat
what that means is the value of parent
node is always greater than or equal to
the value of child node in the heap or
other way around the value of parent
node is less than or equal to the value
of child node for all nodes in a heap
further there are two types of heap
named as max heap and minimum heat
first we will look into maxi
the max heap is heap in which value of
parent node is greater than the value of
child node
for this particular example of max heap
you can see that the root node is the
biggest element in tree and each child
node is smaller than its parent node
the next type of heap is minimum heat
the mean heap is heap in which the value
of parent node is less than the value of
child node
in this specific example you can observe
that each child node is larger than its
parent node and the element at the root
node is smallest element of the heat
both the structures that we have
discussed are binary heats as every node
has only two children in upcoming slides
we'll discuss some complex structures of
heap data structure to better understand
how we can judge if a tree like
structure is heap or not
okay so you can see a tree like
structure on your screen and we are
supposed to check whether if it is a
valid heap data structure or not but
actually here i would like you all to
give it a try by yourself you can also
pause this video if you want but here i
will provide you with a short moment to
inspect this structure
all right i can clearly say that this is
not a valid heap data structure as you
can observe the highlighted part is
violating the heap invariant
moving forward let's analyze another
tree-like data structure to consider if
it is a valid heap or not
well yes this is a valid heap because
even though this one is strangely
structured we are free to move around
the visual representation of nodes to
make it organize now you all must be
thinking how we can do that well we'll
understand that scenario in upcoming
slides
now
how about this one is this a valid heap
no right this is not a valid heap this
structure is not even a tree as it forms
a closed cycle and every heap must be a
tree so it's pretty clear that this is
not a valid heap
now
what about this one
is this a valid heap
yes this is a valid heap as it satisfies
the heap invariant that all the child
nodes must be greater than or equal to
or smaller than or equal to its parent
node
now this is the last structure that we
are going to check if it is a valid heap
or not
what you guys think
is this a valid heap
well i think it's pretty clear that this
is not a valid heap but it can be
converted into a heap by making a one
small change now
if we make six as our root node then
this structure will get converted into a
maxie which is absolutely a valid heap
i hope you all are clear with the heap
invariant and how to judge if a given
tree is a valid heap or not
now moving ahead we'll discuss the
different types of priority queue
basically there are two types of
priority queue based on the priority of
elements if the element with smallest
value has highest priority then that
priority queue is called as min priority
queue and if element with higher value
has the highest priority then that
priority q is known as max priority
queue furthermore it's vividly clear
that the mean priority queue can be
implemented with a minimum heap where
the max priority queue can be
implemented using maximum heap
moving ahead we'll deal with the
operations in priority queue considering
the heap as implementation strategy
the common operations that we can
perform on priority queue are insertion
deletion and peak but there is one more
hidden additional operation that gets
performed during these operations that
operation is called as hippie fire
heavify manages the priority of data
elements in a heap by shuffling the data
elements after new insertion or deletion
first of all we will understand how
insertion in priority queue happens with
the help of an example
in this example we are inserting a new
data element that is 43
but due to this insertion the structure
disobeys the priority queue invariant
that the parent node of the max priority
queue must be greater than its child
node
now the hippie pi operation solves this
problem by rearranging data elements by
carrying out the comparison
in this particular case 43 becomes the
parent node where 40 becomes the child
node
the next step is deletion
as we know the highest priority element
will be the first to leave the priority
queue and further it is stored at the
root node of a max heap so definitely
the element present at the root node
will get removed
but due to this operation the order of
priority q gets affected however the
hippify operation comes to the rescue it
reshuffles the elements of the priority
queue to rearrange them in order
the next operation that we are going to
discover is peak
the peak operation simply returns the
element present at root node without
removing it and it is easily accessible
thus the time complexity of this
operation is big of 1.
i hope you all are clear with the
operations that can be performed on
priority queue moving forward we'll try
to implement them with the help of
minimum heap
as discussed earlier while implementing
a heap data structure we know that all
the elements will get stored in an array
and we don't have any pointers pointing
to either child or parent nodes so how
exactly does the heap data structure
remember nodes like parent nodes and its
left or right nodes
well if you have learnt binary trees
then you must know the formulas present
on your screen these formulas determine
the left child right child or even the
parent node of any binary tree
let's understand how this phenomenon
works with the help of an example we'll
begin with index 0. if we enter 0 in
this arithmetic expression then we will
get 1 and 2 as output that means the
element at index 1 will be the left
child and element at index 2 will be the
right child and tree structure will look
like this
now moving ahead let's take an example
of index 1. for index 1 the left child
will be at index 3 and the right child
will be at index 4.
similarly for index 2 the left child
will be at index 5 where the right child
will be at index 6. using these formulas
we'll be implementing heavify and
primary queue operations so note them
down for further reference
now moving further we will visit code
editor to implement priority queue data
structure using c programming language
previously i mentioned that heap is
implemented using arrays so to begin
with heap implementation primarily we
will create a structure consisting of
different variables or objects needed to
implement heap data structure so let's
create a structure struct
heap
consist in
size
and
count variable
and
end
star
heap
array
which is a dynamic array that we are
creating here
and next we'll also declare a pointer to
heap structure along with size and count
variable in a global scope so let's do
that end
star
heap
comma
size
comma
count
we'll create one more variable end
initial
underscore size
to represent the initial size of our
priority queue and let's assign it value
4 for now
okay
now it's time to allocate memory to our
heap array for this purpose we'll create
a new function called heap underscore
init so let's create this function void
heap
underscore init
and inside it will pass an argument
struct
heap
star
h
which is a reference of this structure
that we created previously
okay
in this function let's initialize the
variables that we have created inside
this heap structure
so for that we'll initialize h
arrow operator
count
is equal to zero
similarly
h
arrow operator
size
size
is equal to
initial
underscore size
and
h
array
is equal to
end
star
malloc
size of
end
star 4
this statement is just allocating four
integer variables to our heap array
basically our heap array is dynamic data
structure that's why we have to provide
it with dynamic memory using malloc if
you are using c plus programming
language to implement this data
structure then you can use new instead
of malloc
moving forward
now we'll work on our condition f
not h
arrow operator
allocates memory to heap array then
printf
error
while
allocating
the memory
and
that slash one
next
we will write exit command
okay
okay
with this we have successfully
implemented our heap init function
now moving ahead let's implement heavify
function to move the nodes
for that
we'll create a heavy five function
void
max underscore
hippify
int
star
data
end
log
and
count
so all these are required variables to
implement this hepify function that we
have passed in argument for this
maximize function
now let's create few more variables that
we need
and left
comma right
comma largest
comma temp
now as discussed earlier left
will be equal to
two
star
location
in array plus
1
and
right
will be equal to
left
plus
one
now let's
say largest is equal to loc
and
we'll work on conditions now
f
left
it's greater than or equal to
count
and
data
left
is
greater than
data
largest
that it's
the location we have stored in largest
variable
then
largest
is equal to
left
with this block what we are doing is we
are checking if the element at location
left is greater than the element at
recent position and the value at left is
also greater than the value of recent
location if these conditions are true
then we will set the recent location as
left and here we are getting signal that
there is semicolon missing over here so
we'll add it
okay
now let's work on next condition
now we will check the value at right
position if the recent location is
greater than the right and the value at
right is greater than the largest value
then element at largest will be set to
right so for that we'll write condition
f
write
its
data
count
and and
data
right
it's greater than
data
largest
then
largest
is equal to
right otherwise if
largest
it's not equal to
location
then
we will store
the data present at location in
temporary variable
and
data
loc
is equal to data
largest
this is a swapping operation that we are
carrying out here
and next data
largest
is equal to
10
and now
we'll make recursive call to our hipfire
function
max underscore
if i
data
comma
largest
comma count
with this we have successfully completed
our hippify function
now we will work on insertion operation
on priority queue let's call this
function heap underscore push
because we are treating this structure
as heap right
so
in heap insertion is called as push
operation so we'll call it
void
heap underscore push and we'll pass
arguments
struct
heap
star
h
and
value
and inside this function will create few
more
variables and index
and
parent
if you guys remember the initial size
that we have allocated to our array is
16 bytes
you can verify with this statement here
that we are providing 16 byte size to
our heap array
but what if you want to insert elements
more than 4 then what we'll do
well for that we'll need to increase the
size of our heap array so we'll do that
here
for this resize we'll create if
condition
f
h
dot
count
is equal to equal to
h
dot
size
then
h
dot size
plus equal to
1
and h
dot
heap
array
is equal to
real lock
h
dot
heap array
size of
end
star
h
dot
sides
basically we are using reallock function
in c
to extend the dynamic memory space for
our heap array and in order to increase
the size we have to increment the size
variable first so that's what we have
done in this statement here
and now once done with this we'll check
if our dynamic memory is getting
allocated or not so for that we'll add
one more if condition inside this if
block so it can be called as nested if
you guys want
dot
keep array
then
exit
-1
now we will move out of this if block
and we will set index variable
to
h
dot
count
plus plus
basically we are iterating with help of
index variable here so
next
we'll add for condition
for loop
index
to
index
is equal to
parent
and then set this condition
will make parent node
is equal to
index
minus 1
by
2.
this is nothing but the formula that we
have discussed
in previous
part
now
we'll add one more condition inside this
for loop f
h
dot
heap array
parent
it's greater than or equal to
value
then
we will
break this for you
otherwise
h dot
heap array
index
will be equal to
h
dot
keep array
parent
now we'll move outside this for loop and
we'll add one more condition of
insertion that is h
dot
heap array
and at
position index
we will
add the value provided by
user using
argument to heap push function
okay with this we have successfully
created our heap push function now we
will move towards the next function
that is
heap underscore delete for that we will
create new function heap
underscore delete
and
let's make this function
integer
and we'll pass
struct
heap
star
h as an argument
we will create one more
variable
temp
is equal to
etch
arrow operator
heap
array
and
inside this will pass
a negating index that means we are using
this temporary variable to traverse
through all list of elements so for that
we'll write
dot dot minus minus
h
arrow operator
count
which will
decrease count one by one
now next we'll add condition f
h
arrow operator
count
it's greater than or equal to
edge
arrow operator
sides
plus
2
and and
h
arrow operator
size
it's also greater than the initial
underscore
size
okay
then
what we will do is we will
set
size
to negate itself
by 1
for each action and then
we will
add
h arrow operator
heap
array
is equal to
real lock
h
dot
heap
array
comma
size of
end
star
h
arrow operator
and size
sorry
size
and semicolon
so basically what we are doing here is
we are checking if count is smaller than
the size of heap plus 2
and and the dynamic size of q is also
larger than initialized size that is 4
then what we are doing is we are
reducing the size for deleting an
element using this statement
and in next statement we are
reallocating that deleted space
so this is how this ip block works
now moving forward we'll add a condition
to check if memory is getting
allocated or not for that we'll write
condition f
not h
arrow operator
heap array
then
what we'll do is exit
with
-1
okay
now let's move out of this block
and now we will
set this removed variable to
h
arrow operator
heap array
and index zero
so if you guys remember
zero is the index of the highest element
in our maximum heap
what i mean here is the element with
highest value is stored at index 0 for
maxi
now moving forward to delete this
element what we'll do is
we will set
h
dot
heap array
and index 0
is equal to
temporary variable
or pointer that we have created
previously
and
next what we'll do is we'll call max
underscore hippie five function
to
rearrange the structure of our priority
queue which has been shuffled due to
this delete operation
now for that we'll
pass arguments
our heap structure
that is heap array
and next
the index which was removed and
the count
variable
and will
return the remove element
okay with this we have successfully
implemented our delete function
now to understand the order of deletion
in priority queue we will implement one
more function called as mtpq
so let's create this
function and in this function will pass
the reference of heap structure in order
to operate on it so let's pass
the structure
here
star
h
and insert this function
we will create a while loop
h
dot
count
is not equal to
zero
then
printf
modulus d
and
recursive call to
keep
delete
function
in which will pass h
now
we are done with this empty pq function
further we will create one more function
to visualize our priority queue
let's call this function
void
heap
underscore display
and inside this will pass
structure
heap
star
h
and
now
we will create one iterator element
and
using that iterator element will create
for loop i is equal to 0
to
i
it's greater than
arrow operator
count
plus plus i
and inside this for loop we will print
the elements present in our queue using
this format
modulus d
and we'll call
heap
array but for that we'll need to call
structure as well
if array and
will pass
this
item variable into it
okay
and then next we'll get outside this for
loop and we'll print f
this to the next line using slash n
okay
now we have implemented all the required
function for our priority queue moving
forward we'll work on our driver
function that is main method to
contemplate the result of our program so
for that we'll first call struct
heap edge
then we'll call
init function to create heap
structure
so heap init
and we'll pass
the address of h
next
we will call
heap
underscore push function
to insert element
and h
comma
one
next
i'll copy this
part
with paste it to insert another element
now we'll insert five here
next
paste and we'll
pause three
next we'll insert element 7
next we'll
insert element 9
and after this we'll insert element 8.
okay
so now
let's display the elements inside our
key
using heap underscore display function
and let's pause and h
object to print it and
again
we'll call
mtpq function
empty
pq
and after deleting all elements
it will return the state of our heap
array again or our priority q so finally
we'll add return zero statement
and now our code
is ready so let's compile it and check
it if it works fine or not
so we are getting four errors here guys
so we'll need to resolve them
first we'll need to check line number 82
so for 82
okay here we haven't added semicolon
so i think this should be fine now still
we have two errors
before i
it's there
so let's recompile it and check it if it
is working fine now
so we have received our output now now
if you look at our output our output is
printing elements 9 7 8 1 5 and 3 and
deletion of elements is also happening
according to their order so 9 is getting
deleted first after 8 7 5 3 and 1.
so
that means our elements are getting
removed in proper order further we can
say that our program for priority queue
implementation works fine
now if you guys are worried about this
program then not to worry we have you
covered you can mention your email ids
in comment box below and we will send it
over to you remember guys we can make
comments private to protect all your
data so you can fearlessly put all your
email ids in comment box below
now we will discuss applications of
priority queue to understand its
importance
the first application that we are going
to discuss is use of priority queue in
google maps you must have used google
maps several times to navigate from one
city to another or from your location to
nearest desired location have you ever
wondered how google maps managed to do
that how does it provide an optimal path
to reach your location
well dijkstra's shortage path algorithm
implemented in google maps actually
manages to do that by gaining access to
all possible paths this algorithm uses
the priority queue to maintain all the
paths in order let's understand how it
works in detail
now when you provide the location of
place you want to reach via your mobile
device google maps feeds the data of all
possible path to digikestra's algorithm
those paths or road are stored in
minimum priority queue considering the
distance as parameter for priority
assignment and we have learned that the
minimum priority queue maintains the
lowest value at the print or root node
this is how the priority queue helps
google map to search for an ideal path
for reaching destination location
the next application that we are going
to discuss is data compression in winzip
or gzip these applications use hubman
encoding algorithm to reduce the size of
files hupman coding is a lossless data
compression algorithm and in this
algorithm a variable link code is
assigned to input different characters
the code length is related to how
frequent characters are used most
recurring characters have the smallest
codes and longer codes are for the least
frequent characters this is how the
generated codes will maintain the
complete data while utilizing less
memory space
let's understand how this process works
with the help of an example let's say
our text file contains these random
characters
the hubman encoding algorithm creates
codes for each character based on its
number of occurrences for instance the
frequency of character a is more
prominent than b and character c has
less frequency so the length of code a
is smaller than b and length of code b
will be smaller than c
now
according to the amount of generated
code the priority queue will determine
the priority of characters and will
store them these codes takes less size
than the actual characters in memory
space and due to the mapping of
occurrences
data does not get lost
i hope now you guys understand why the
priority queue is treated as an abstract
data structure itself and why it is the
better version of queue data structure
we'll start this discussion by
understanding what is double ended queue
in data structure followed by that we'll
understand the properties of dq in
detail advancing ahead will deal with
the different types of dequeue after
that we'll understand the representation
of dq using circular queue and further
we'll discuss different operations that
can be performed on dq
once finish with that we'll implement a
dq using circular queue and finally
we'll cover applications of dq to
understand its importance
i hope i made myself clear with the
agenda now let's get started with our
first topic what is dq
dq is an abbreviation for double ended
queue and as the term double ended queue
suggests it is a type of queue with some
advanced features at both of its ends
but previously we have learned that the
basic queue data structure must perform
insertion from one of its end and
deletion from another or opposite end
so what new limitation of feature does
this particular type of queue brings
well the dq extends the concept of a
linear queue by implementing insertion
and deletion at both of its nodes
by that what i mean is the dq data
structure is acquainted with the
possibility to insert and delete new
elements at any node that is why dq is
concerned as more generalized version of
queue data structure
now moving ahead we shall understand the
key properties of dq
the first property of dq states that the
dq can use the lipo principle for
inserting or removing elements the last
in first dot principle is used while
implementing stacked data structure and
according to this principle the queue
elements must be inserted from one end
and should also be removed from the same
end
for instance we are storing some
elements inside this queue structure
which is performing both insertion and
deletion from one end
however when deletion begins the element
inserted at last will be removed first
whereas the element stored at first will
get removed at the end this property
clears that the dq can inherit all the
properties of stack data structure
the next property of dq states that the
dq can use the fifo principle for
performing both insertion and deletion
operations
that means the element which enters
inside the queue at beginning will also
leave the queue at first
further the element which entered at
last can leave the queue at last both of
these properties displays the uniqueness
of this particular type of queue data
structure
now in upcoming slides we will
understand different types of the dq
the first type of dq we have is termed
as input restricted queue
this terminology itself suggests that
this particular type of dq will have
some restrictions while performing nq or
insertion operation
in this type of dq the insertion can
only be performed from one end where
deletion can be performed at both of its
ends the representation of dq shown
below explains how the operations in
this type of dq will get accomplished
the next type of dq is output restricted
dq
this term makes clear that this type of
queue will have some restrictions while
performing deletion operations
in this specific type of queue the
removal of elements can only be
performed from one eight where the
insertion can be performed at both of
its eights this particular structure of
a queue explains how the different
operations will take place in this type
of dq
now here is the interesting question
that we want you all to answer based on
the properties of dq that we have
discussed till now which of the
following data structure will be more
ideal for implementing dq in data
structure
what i mean by ideal is the time and
space complexity for implementation
strategy that you decide should be
minimum
the options that we have are
circular array
singly linked list and doubly linked
list
it will be interesting to see how many
of you guys will get this right
so guys do leave your answers to this
question in comment section below in a
week's time we'll be announcing the
right answer and you all can check it
out
on that note let's dive further and
understand the representation of dq
using circular queue and yes
circular queue is one of the answers for
previous questions we'll understand why
it is best in upcoming slides but please
check the complexity analysis of other
two strategies to decide your answer for
the previous question as multiple
answers can be accurate for that
question
now let's understand what a circular
queue is
well a circular queue is nothing but the
extended notion of linear q as it
follows the first in first out principle
with the exception that the last
position of this particular queue is
connected to its first position making a
circular link
the circular link is responsible for
naming of this queue as circular queue
or ring buffer let's understand how a
circular queue operates with the help of
simulation
this is the illustration of a circular
queue having size 5. as the position of
rear pointer keeps increasing a new
element will be inserted in this queue
until the rear pointer reaches the end
of q
but what if we perform dq operation now
if we perform the deletion then the
empty space will get created at front of
q however this space can further be
utilized in this particular type of
queue by making circular incrementation
of rear pointer or circular link
so if we increment the rear pointer from
its index 5 to index 0 we can utilize
empty space by making new insertions
using this feature of circular queue we
can implement both insertion and
deletion at both the ends of q
let's understand how we can do that in
upcoming slides
the first type of insertion is a pretty
ordinary one and this insertion will
increment the position of rear pointer
to insert a new element the arrow shown
in blue is rear pointer and the arrow
shown in orange is the front pointer so
as you can see once we increment the
rear pointer new elements get inserted
this is how the insertion using rear
node happens
now what if we want to perform insertion
using front end in order to perform the
insertion using front node we'll have to
make front pointer reach to the end of
queue the only possible way to achieve
that is to set front pointer equal to
max size minus 1 manually
this command will allow a front pointer
to reach the end of queue for performing
insertion and for further insertions
we'll just have to decrement the front
pointer location for inserting new
elements this is all about insertion
now that we have implemented insertion
from both ends let's move on to the
deletion operation
primarily we'll look into the deletion
using front node in order to delete
elements using front node we'll have to
increment the front pointer until it
reaches the end of q and once it reaches
the max size we'll use circular
incrementation to bring the front
pointer to the beginning of queue while
performing these incrementation
meanwhile the elements will be removed
from the queue
next up is deletion using rear end for
performing deletion using a rear pointer
we'll have to decrement its location
once we decrement the rear pointer
location the element will get removed
from the queue
now moving ahead we'll look into the
different operations that can be
performed on a double ended queue
basically there are four primary
operations in the dq which we have
already understood in the representation
of dq using circular queue
these operations are insertion and
deletion at the front and insertion and
deletion at the rear
additionally the circular queue
implementation of dq cost us big of 1
which is the most optimal complexity
that we can hope for
having said that let's dive into the
implementation of these operations using
a circular queue
we'll implement a double ended queue
using circular queue in order to do that
we'll use c programming language and one
dimensional arrays so without wasting
any time further let's move to the code
editor
now in order to get started with
implementation of dq we'll have to
create array and pointer variables so
let's do that
and
we'll name this array as dq
and we'll provide 100 as initial size
next we'll create pointers
and
rear
is equal to minus 1.
now we'll also define the maximum size
for our queue using define call
as 5.
after done with this initialization
process we'll start working on insertion
from front node will declare a function
named as voidfront insert so let's do
that void
front
underscore
insert
and instead this function will pass an
argument into z to insert an element
now while performing insertion we should
always check if the queue is full or not
because if it is full then the insertion
won't be possible so for that we'll
write condition
if
front
is equal to equal to zero
and
and rear
it's equal to equal to size
minus one
inside
and braces
or
front
is equal to equal to rhea
plus one
printf
dq
as
full
insertion
it's not possible
okay
otherwise if both the front and rear
node are pointing to null memory index
or -1 will manually set our front
pointer to index 0 to make the first
insertion into the queue
and we will insert the element at new
location or index 0 where the front
pointer is pointing so for that
what we'll do is we'll write another
condition with lc block
else if
front
is equal to equal to
-1
and and
zea
is equal to equal to minus one
then
make front
is equal to rhea is equal to 0
and
dq
front
is equal to
z
now if we want to insert the element at
the last node of q then we need to set
front pointer to the max size -1
location to do that we'll write this
condition
else
if
front
is equal to equal to zero
then
front
is equal to
size
minus 1
and dq
front
is equal to z
if all these above mentioned conditions
fail then the front pointer is already
at the last part of q
and it just need to decrement its
location for inserting element in empty
spaces as discussed previously so to do
that we'll write one more condition
using else block so let's do that
else
front
is equal to front
minus 1
and dq
front
is equal to z
now we have successfully implemented
a front insert function so let's move
forward and work on another function
that is called as void
rear
underscore insert
and will pass
g as an argument to insert an element
now as done previously we will first
check if our queue is full or not so
let's do that using if condition if
front
is equal to equal to zero
and at
ria
is equal to equal to size minus 1
inside braces
or
front
is equal to equal
equal to equal to
rear
plus 1
then
printf
dq
is full
next if there is no element in an array
we'll manually set the rear pointer to
index 0 for new insertion so for that
we'll write condition else f
front
it's equal to equal to minus 1
and and
rear
it's equal to equal to minus 1
then
set rear
is equal to 0
and
insert
dq
ria
is equal to z
otherwise if rear pointer is already at
the end of q then we will bring it to
the beginning of q so for that we'll
write condition
else f
rear
is equal to equal to size
minus 1
then
being
rear
to index zero
and dq
rear
it's
equal to z
if all these mentioned conditions fail
then what we'll do is we'll write else
condition and we'll simply increment our
rear pointer to make an insertion so for
that what we'll do is we'll create else
block and we're inside it
we will
do rear plus plus
and we will set dq
rear
is equal to c
with this we have successfully
implemented void rear insert function so
now let's move into deletion functions
first we'll create void front dq
function void
front
underscore dq
and there is no need for any argument
for this function
to begin with this function first we'll
have to check if dq is empty because we
cannot delete elements if there is no
element to delete so for that we'll
write f condition if
front
it's equal to equal to minus 1
and and
rear
is equal to equal to minus 1
then
printf
there is no element
to
delete
inside
this
dq
in the next condition we'll check if
there is only one element inside the dq
if there is only one element then we
will set both front and rear to minus 1
manually for that what we'll do is we'll
create else if condition
else if front
is equal to equal to zero
then
printf
let's slash in to take this to the next
line
the
deleted
element
from
the front
is
modulus d
comma
dq
front
and we will set front
is equal to minus 1
similarly
real
is equal to minus 1.
now if both these above mentioned
conditions fail then we will delete the
element from our front node
the first removal will be in a case when
the front pointer is at the end of queue
so for that we'll write condition else
if
front
it's at end of queue that its
size -1
and what we'll do is
we will printf
slash and
the deleted
element
from
the front
is
modulus
d
comma
dq
front
comma
and another condition will be when the
front pointer is at the beginning
section of a cube for that
we'll write else condition
printf
slash n
the deleted
element
from the front is
modulus d
comma d2
front
with this we have successfully
implemented our front dq function now
let's move towards next function that is
deletion from the rear end for that
we'll create new function name
void
dq
underscore rear
and this function also does not need any
argument so next
what we'll do is we'll create condition
to check if the queue is empty or not
so
if front
is equal to equal to minus 1
and and
rear
is equal to equal to -1
then
printf
printf
slash n
there is no element
to
delete
inside the queue
now let's move to the next condition
in next condition we'll write else f
front
is equal to equal to rhea
then
printf
some statement
and
set
run
is equal to minus 1
along with rear is equal to
-1
and that statement will be
the
deleted
element
from
the dq
using
rear
node
as
modulus d
comma
dq
rhea
now
if both these above mentioned conditions
fail then we'll have to delete the
element from our real node the first
removal will be in a case when rear is
at the beginning portion of a queue for
that let's write a condition
else if
rear
is equal to equal to 0 that is at the
beginning part of q
then
printf
some statement
and
rear
is equal to size minus 1 that is setting
it to the max size of cube
and the statement that we will return is
backslash n
the deleted
element
from
the rear
node
adds
modulus d
comma
dq
rear
in other cases we'll just have to
decrement the size of rear pointer and
delete the element so for that we'll
write else condition
printf
some statement
and
set rear
is equal to
rear
minus
1 that is decrementing the size of rear
pointer and the statement that we'll
write as backslash n
the
deleted
element
from
the rear
node
as modulus d
and comma
dq
rear
well here is one spelling mistake so
let's remove it
okay
so with this we have successfully
implemented our void dq rear function
now we will implement one more function
to display the state of our
dq
the name of that function will be void
display
and this function also does not need any
argument
so we'll begin with implementation of
this function for this we'll create an
iterator element and we'll set it to the
front
pointer
and we will printf
backslash n
elements
inside
the
dub
double
ended
queue
r
next line
will enter into while loop to print
those element
i
not equal to
rear
printf
modulus
d
comma
dq
i
and
will increase the value of i
by
i plus
one
modulus
size
and
outside this while loop we will printf
modulus d
dq
ria
okay
with this we have implemented all the
required functionalities for our dq so
let's work on driver method that is main
function
in order to check the output of our
program so
let's work on this main function first
we will insert
few elements into our queue so i will
insert first element using front insert
next let's insert one more element from
front node
using function front insert
and this element will be 23
next we will insert elements using rear
node
underscore insert
and we'll pass 17 now
next we'll insert
12
and
we'll insert one more element using this
rear node only
insert
47
now we will display
the state of our queue after performing
all these operations
and next we will
dq
few elements
so for that we'll use front dq function
and next
we will dequeue
from
real node
so
dq here
and after performing deletion operations
will also display the state of our queue
so let's call display once again
and let's add one more command
return
zero
so with this we have successfully
implemented our program
for dq implementation so let's run it
and check if it is working fine or not
okay so we are getting output here
but uh
display function is printing output in
weird manner so let's
work it out
so all we have to do is we'll have to
add space before modulus t here
and here as well
so
once done with this let's
recompile our code
okay
so now our output is clear so let's
check if it is
perfect or not
so
the first insertion that we made was -5
second was 23 from the front end so 5
should be getting inserted before 23
so minus 5 is getting inserted before 23
but as we are inserting it using front
pointer so 23 is remaining at the front
now
after these two insertions we are
performing insertions using rear pointer
the first rear insertion was 17 then 12
then 47 and these elements are getting
inserted
so let me show you how they are getting
inserted in exact same order
so
look here so elements inside the double
ended q are 23 minus 5 17 12 and 47 that
means the insertion is in right order
after that we deleted the element from
front node so the front node is at 23 so
23 is getting deleted after that we
deleted the element using rear node so
47 is getting deleted from the
rear node
we are still getting 23 here that means
the tq function is incomplete so we'll
have to change it so let's go to the dq
function
and i guess it was from
front end so we'll need to change code
for our front dq
so okay
so in this case we haven't brought our
trend pointer
to index 0 so let's do that here and
once we do this let's
recompile our code again
okay so now you can see that the 23 is
getting deleted
with this we have successfully
implemented our dq function
now let's move back to the powerpoint
and understand few applications of dq
the first application that we are going
to discuss in detail is palindrome
checker you all must have heard about
the term palindrome
the palindrome is a specific word or
number which reads the same backward as
forward for example the word radar it
reads the same from both ends so using
the dq we can implement the palindrome
checker program with complexity big of
1.
the string which you need to check will
be inserted into a dq and after that it
will read from both sides if the reading
is the same then that string will be
considered as palindrome
the next application of dq is its use in
multiprocessor scheduling
but what precisely is multiprocessor
scheduling and why do we need it well
the system implemented in the old days
use single processor scheduling to
manage the computing processes
when multiple processes need to be
executed by a single core or cpu then
the process take more time to implement
and thus the system lacks computing
power
but the multi-processor scheduling
implemented in modern computers resolves
that problem using a double ended queue
suppose we have three processors in our
system and each processor has some
processors to execute each processor
maintains a dq that contains threads
that are ready to execute the processor
executes a process and if a process
creates a child process then that
process will be inserted at the front of
the dq of parent process suppose the
processor p2 has completed the execution
of all its threads then it steals the
thread from the rear end of processor p1
and adds it to the front end of the
processor p2 the processor p2 will take
the thread from front end therefore the
deletion takes from both the ends
this is also known as a still algorithm
in process scheduling what is a stack so
to define stack in a more generalized
way we can consider stack as a linear
data structure that follows lifo order
or lost in first out order or another
way of putting it down as first come
last out order
so some of the basic operations that can
be performed on stack are insertion and
deletion and that can be done only at
the end which is called as the top of
the stack
now let us understand the basic
operations on stack so the three
fundamental operations that can be
applied onto a data structure like stack
are push pop and peak so the push
operation involves inserting a new
element from the top of the stack the
pop operation involves removing the
element from the top of the stack and
finally the peak operation which returns
the topmost element from the stack
without removing the element from the
stack
now we shall go through some generalized
examples of stack
so some of the generalized examples of
stack are you can see a stack of books
here and a stack of utensils stack of
coins and stack of dollars of bills
now let us go through a practical
example based on stack and data
structures we shall be using c
programming language for this particular
example
so you can see that on my screen i have
an example for stack data structure
don't worry about the code this code
will be attached in the description box
below and you can always have access to
it and you can run the same code in your
personal system so that you have a
deeper and better understanding of the
program now let's quickly run this
program
so there you go you can see the program
is getting executed now
so you can see that the program got
successfully executed and the elements
are being inserted into the stack
now the elements are a b
and finally the elements are popped back
again that is b a and the last element
that is popped away from the stack is a
and you can see that the stack is
currently empty so top is pointing to -1
now with that let's get back to the
presentation again
now let us understand some of the
applications of stack
so one of the applications of stack is
function call or recursion the recursive
function call is also known as the
called stack whenever a function is
called then the function goes to the top
of the stack
now another important application of
stack is expression conversion there are
three types of notations that is prefix
notation inflectionation and postfix
notation so these particular notations
can be taken care by using stacks in
real time
now the next one is checking parenthesis
stack is used to check if the given
parenthesis are balanced or not
sometimes if you forget to add a
parenthesis then the compiler will throw
an error so using stack this can be
found if there are balanced parenthesis
used in your program or not balanced
parenthesis means opening and closing
brackets are of the same type that means
if you have
two open flower brackets then you need
to have two closed flower brackets it
should not be an equal it should be
completely equal to complete the code
segment
now another application of stack is
expression evaluation stack can be used
to evaluate the expressions as you can
see here we have an expression that is 6
plus 2 star 3 minus 12 divided by 4.
now this particular expression will be
evaluated based on the presidency table
so the stack is used to check the
precedence and then the expression gets
evaluated into the result which is 21
right over here
now another application is the tower of
hanoi tower of hanoi is a mathematical
puzzle which consists of three rods and
n number of discs of different diameters
all the discs are placed on one rod one
over the other and in ascending order of
size similarly into a cone-shaped tower
now we will enter into the next segment
where we will discuss about queues so
what exactly is a queue a queue is a
linear data structure that follows the
fifo order that is the first and first
out
whereas stack followed first in last out
so this is one of the fundamental
difference between stacks and queues so
we'll be discussing those in the next
section
for now let's continue with the
operations on queue the queue is an
ordered list in which insertion is done
at one end that is called here and
deletion is done at another end which is
called front the operations on queue are
enqueue operation that adds a new item
to the queue if the queue is complete
then there is an overflow condition
dq operation is the operation which
deletes an item from the queue and if
the queue is empty then there is an
underflow condition through it as an
exception
now let us understand some of the
basic examples of q you can consider the
patients at hospital registration and
you can also consider an example of
customers making use of atm
now let us understand the types of queue
so there are basically three types of
queues those are circular queues doubly
ended queues and priority queues
now let us understand the circular queue
in a circular queue the last element
points to the first element to form a
circular link
circular queue is also known as ring
buffer insertion is done at the rear and
deletion is done at the front as
discussed before
now we will go through the doubly ended
queue in doubly ended queue both
insertion and deletion can be done at
both rear and front of the queue
now the last one the priority queue in
the priority queue the notes have same
predefined priority insertion can be
done as the arrival of the nodes node
having the least priority will be the
first node removed from the queue now we
will go through a general practical
example of queues and then we will go
through the applications of queues now
on my screen you can see an example for
queues don't worry about the code this
code will be attached in the description
box below and you can always have access
to it and learn executing this on your
own system so without further ado let's
start to execute this code
so you can see that the code got
successfully executed and the terminal
is asking for us to give an operation so
the first one is to insert an element
into the queue second one is to delete
an element and the third one is to
display the elements in the queue and
the fourth one is to quote let's insert
so now let us insert an element into the
queue that is 10.
now let's try to display the elements in
the queue for that i need to select the
option number three
and there you go the queue has element
number 10. now let's try to delete that
element for that we might have to choose
the second option
so you can see that the element got
deleted from the queue and the element
deleted from the queue is 10
and
you have another choice now so
let's try to quit it now so that i need
to select the option for because we have
seen how to insert view and delete the
element let's not make further delay and
let's quickly enter into the next part
of our session that is the application
of cues
so the first application of queue is
breadth first search
breadth first search or bfs traverses a
graph in a breadthward direction and
uses a queue to remember the next node
to start a search
the second application is level order
traversal entry level order traversal
processes all the nodes of a tree by
depth first the root then the children
of the source
next one is first come first serve cpu
scheduling first come first serve fcfs
is an operating system algorithm that
works on cued requests and implements
them according to their arrival
now the fibonacci
fibonacci heap is a data structure that
implements priority queue operations
consisting of the collection of heap
order trees
now our last segment that is the
comparison between stack and queue
so at first both stack and queue are
linear data structures and stack follows
last in first out whereas q follows
first in and first out and when you are
considering stack the insertion takes
place at the top
and deletion takes place from the top as
well
whereas when it comes to stack the
insertion starts from rear but deletion
or elimination of the element from the
queue starts from the front
in stacks the insert operation is called
as push
and deletion process is called as pop
in queues the insertion is called as
enqueue and deletion is called as dq
in stacks you mainly maintain one
pointer to access the list that is
called top which always points to the
last element present in the list in
queues we maintain two different
pointers the first one is the front
pointer which always points to the front
element or the first element inserted in
the list and the next one is the rare
pointer which always points to the rare
or the last element inserted into the
list
stack is used in solving problems that
work on recursion whereas q is used in
solving problems having sequential
processing so these are the fundamental
differences between stacks and queues
what is a tree data structure
so what exactly is a tree data structure
the tree is a non-linear data structure
that consists of nodes and is connected
by edges i know it's a little difficult
to understand just by the definition so
let me show you the pictorial
representation
as you can see we have the elements that
is 10 20 30 40 50 60 and 70 and all
these are stored in the tree data
structure they are stored in a
non-linear structure if we had used
arrays it would have been in a linear
consecutive way where 10 starts first
and 70 ends at the last position
now in the next section we will discuss
why we had made to a switch to the tree
data structure when we already had a
linear data structure that is airy
now the next topic that is why we need
tree data structure
so there are many reasons why we have
switched into tree data structure and
one of the reason is a linear data
structure always stores the elements in
a sequential form that is one after the
other and in operations to be performed
in linear data structure the time
complexity increases as the data size
increases you can see here that as
discussed before the elements are stored
in a linear form that is 10 at the first
place and 70 at the last place imagine
you wanted to access the element 70 then
using the traversal you had to start
from the first position that is 10 20 30
40 and slowly at the end is 70. so
accessing that particular element is
really time consuming we are facing this
just for 70 elements imagine if we had
700 elements
right so that is exactly why we had made
a switch to tree data structure and
using tree data structure we have many
advantages as the tree data structure is
completely non-linear and it allows
easier access and quicker access of the
data elements how is that possible we
will look into it into the next segment
where we will discuss about the
traversal of trees
now before we understand the traversal
of trees we should understand another
important topic that has the
terminologies of tree
so the first one is the node node is the
entity that contains the keys and
pointer to its child nodes
so here you can see that the elements a
b c d e f and g are the elements so each
and every element or the blue dot is
called as a node and
the blue dots here are
one two three four five six and seven so
we have seven blue dots so we have seven
elements here so you can see the line
between each elements right so this
particular line is called edge now we'll
discuss about the edge in the next part
so the connecting links between any two
nodes are called as edges so we
discussed about the nodes right where
the element is stored the blue dots are
the nodes and the lines connecting
between the elements or nodes is called
as the edge
so out of all the nodes this first node
that is the element a is called as the
root node in a tree data structure
so indirectly root node is also called
as the parent node of all the nodes now
we will understand what are parent nodes
and children nodes
so in a tree data structure the node
that is the node's predecessor is called
as parent node so here we have discussed
that a or the root node is the parent of
all nodes
so for a b and c nodes are children
nodes and for b and c nodes a happens to
be the parent node similarly d and e are
the children nodes of b and f and j are
children nodes of c
and
the
nodes d and e have b as the parent node
and the nodes f and g have c as the
parent node
now followed by that
we will understand the descendant node
so as discussed before the descendant
node is the node that comes after the
parent node here the b and c are the
descendants of a and d and e are
descendants of b and similarly f and g
are the descendants or children of the
node c
so in a tree data structure the node
which does not have any child is called
as the leaf node now at the end we have
d e f and g so these particular nodes do
not have any children nodes like b and c
so these particular four nodes which do
not have any children are called as the
leaf nodes
in a tree data structure the node with
at least one child node is called as the
internal node
so here the internal nodes are p and c
which have at least one child
in a tree the total number of children
of a node are called as the degree of
that node so in this particular diagram
the degree of root node is 2 because it
has 2 child nodes and the degree of b is
2 as it has 2 child nodes similarly the
degree of c is 2 because it has 2 child
nodes but when it comes to d e f and g
the
degree is 0 because they do not have any
child nodes
in a tree data structure the root node
is said to be at level 0 and the
children of the root node are said to be
at level 1 and the children nodes of the
level 1 are at level 2. so to understand
this let's go through the diagram as you
can see this particular root node is
called as level 0
and followed by that we have the
children nodes of a that is b and c and
that level is called as level 1 and
followed by that we have level 2 and if
this tree goes forward the levels also
increase accordingly
in a tree data structure the total
number of edges from a leaf node to the
particular node is the longest path and
this particular path is called as the
height of that node
now here we have our general tree data
structure and here you can see the
height of node a s2
and the height of node b and c together
is at 1 and the height of the last leaf
nodes happens to be
0. next in the tree data structure the
total number of edges from the root node
to a particular node is called as the
depth of that node
now in this particular tree data
structure the depth of the root node is
0 and the depth of b
and c together is 1 because the number
of edges connecting to the
node a from b is just 1 and similarly
the number of edges connecting the node
c from a is just one so the depth of
both b and c is one
now if we consider the last leaf nodes
then the depth is two because if you see
g is connected to a using two different
edges similarly f is connected to a
using two different edges and e and d
also have two nodes to connect to a so
the depth is 2
now in the next segment we will
understand the tree node
so the tree data structure has data part
and references to its left and right
child node in the tree data structure so
here you can see this is the node and
the node has three segments that is data
element and the references towards left
child and the references to its right
child
now there are four different types of
trees the first one is the binary tree
followed by that we have the binary
search tree then we have avl tree and
finally we have the b3 let us discuss
each one of them the first one is the
binary tree a binary tree is a tree data
structure in which each parent node at
most has two children
so in this particular tree we'll have at
most two children that means it might
have one or more than one but not more
than two children per node
moving ahead we have the binary search
tree so a binary search tree or a bsd is
a tree data structure in which each node
has a maximum of two children all nodes
of the left subtree are less than the
right node all nodes on the right
subtree are more than the root node so
here you can see the image or the gif
which represents the image of a binary
search tree so here all the nodes of the
left subtree are less than the root node
and all the nodes of the right subtree
are more than the root node
the next type of the tree is the avl
tree the avl tree got its name after
inventory georgie adelson welsky and
landis
avl tree is the self-balancing tree in
which each node maintains a balanced
factor most value is either one
zero or minus one
balance factor is equals to height of
the left sub tree minus height of the
right subtree or height of the right
subtree minus height of the left subtree
so in this particular image you can
identify it is an avl tree
and now the last type of tree that is
the b3
b3 is a special kind of self-balancing
search tree in which each node can
contain more than one key and can have
more than two children b3 is also known
as the height balanced m way tree now in
this particular gif we can see how a b
tree looks like
now followed by this we will discuss the
tree traversal
so traversing a tree helps to visit
required node in the tree to perform
specific operations tree traversal can
be performed in three different ways
the first one is the pre-order traversal
where we visit the node
and visit all the node from the left
side then visit all the nodes from the
right side so this particular gif is an
example for pre-order traversal where we
visit all the left side nodes first then
we visit the right side nodes
now we will move ahead into the next
type of
traversal that is the in order traversal
first we visit all the nodes from the
left side then we visit the root node
and then represent all the nodes from
the right side so this particular gif
will be an example for the in order
traversal where we visit all the left
side nodes and then we visit the root
node and followed by that we will visit
the right side nodes
and the last type of traversal is the
post order traversal where we visit all
the nodes from the left side first then
revisit all the nodes from the right
side and finally visit the root node
so this particular image on the right
side is an example for post order
traversal now before we get into
learning the applications of trees we
will try to execute one example based on
the post order pre-order and in order
traversals and tree data structure
so you can see that we have an example
on my screen right now so here we have
the node structure
then we have the in order traversal
function followed by that we have the
pre-order traversal function and finally
we have the post order traversal
function now let's quickly run this
program and see the output and don't
worry about the code this particular
code document will be attached in the
description box below and you can have
access to it
now we have the run option over here and
the program got successfully executed
you can ignore this warning and here we
have the in order traversal of the tree
and the first output then we have the
pre-order traversal of the tree and
finally we have the post-order traversal
of the tree now let's discuss the last
part
where we will learn the application of
trees
so the application of trees are as
follows binary search trees are used to
quickly check whether an element is
present in the set or not then we have
the most popular database usage of b3
which is a variant of tree data
structure then we have the modified
version of trees called as trice which
is used in the router to store routing
information and finally the compiler
uses a syntax tree to validate the
syntax of every program you're right
what is tree traversal in data structure
tree traversal is a process of visiting
each and every node in a tree data
structure
so right here on my screen we have a
tree with different nodes that is a
b
c
d
and e
so here we will be visiting all the
nodes one after the other using the tree
traversal methods
now that we have a brief understanding
of what exactly is a tree traversal
process let's get into the next topic of
our discussion for today that is the
data structure used for tree traversal
in a tree data structure there are
primarily two data structures utilized
for tree traversal the first one is the
start data structure and the second one
is the queue data structure
a stack is a linear data structure that
operates on the last in first out lifo
principle there is only one pointer in
the stack that is the top pointer which
points to the stack's topmost element
only the top of the stack is used for
insertion and deletion now the next one
is the queue
a queue unlike stacks is open on both
the ends the one end is always open and
used only for input and the other is
only used for deletion or elimination
the principle followed in queue is
first in first out or fifo approach
followed by that we will look into the
different types of tree traversals in
data structure
tree traversal can be done in the
following ways the first one is breadth
first search and the second one is the
depth first search
first let us have a look at the breadth
first search algorithm or breadth first
search traversal
we follow level order traversal in
breadth first search
breadth first search traverses notes by
level instead of subtrees
first we visit the root node followed by
the root node we visit the left sub tree
of the tree then followed by the left
sub tree we finish the right subtree of
the entire tree
after that we go until the leaf nodes of
the entire tree is found the second one
is the depth first search in depth first
search we traverse three data structure
in three ways that is pre-order
traversal in-order traversal and
post-order traversal
let us take a look at how these
traversals are carried out
first let us discuss the pre-order
traversal
we traverse the root node first in the
pre-order traversal then we traverse
through the left subtree and finally we
traverse through the right subtree
then there is in order traversal in
order traversal involves traversing of
the left subtree first followed by that
we enter the root node then we visit the
right sub tree lastly we have the post
order traversal so post order traversal
involves traversing of left subtree
first then the right sub tree and
finally we visit the root node
now next we will have a look at some of
the important applications of tree
traversal in data structure
so we use tree traversal in data
structures to build a prefix expression
or polish notation from expression trees
then utilize the pre-order traversal and
then traverse the expression tree in a
pre-orderly manner
a binary tree's postfix representation
or reverse polish notation can be
generated using post order traversal
because it returns values from the
underlying set in order according to the
comparator setting up the binary search
tree in order traversal is often
employed on binary search
a complete binary tree can be deleted or
released when deleting or freezing nodes
and values in the post order traversal
now next we will see an example based on
tree traversal in data structures so on
my screen we have an example for tree
traversal in data structure to begin we
have included the enum or user specified
data type traversal it mostly used to
give integral constant names which make
a programmer easier to comprehend and
maintain
we defined three variables in the enum
data type that is pre-order in order and
post order traversal we can define the
type that can take one of the two values
by using the typedef and enum keywords
we have a traversal data type with trap
variable and a node data type with node
variable then we define the node using
the data structure type as struct node
we declare one variable x and two nodes
as a left and right nodes respectively
in this node section
we then attempted to create node using
the create node function passing the
root node as an argument in this code we
use a malloc function to create a node
assign data to x and null to both the
right and left nodes before returning to
the root node
if node t is not equal to null we simply
return it otherwise we will use the
released tree function to release the
left and right nodes and if neither is a
root node then we will use the free
function to release the node t which
will behave as the root node
then we define the display tree function
which takes the trap variable and the
root node as parameters there is a
condition in this function that is if
the root node is not null we will return
the root node then using the switch case
scenario we attempted to traverse the
tree using all three types of traversals
we utilize a trav variable in the switch
function so if any of the inorder
pre-order or post order variables match
the trap variable the traversal will be
executed then we created a tree using
the create tree function which takes a
data variable as input in the create
tree function we used a malloc function
to create the root node and we first
assigned a null to the left and right
nodes as well as the data to the
variable x before returning to the root
node
we first traverse the root node then the
left subtree and finally the right
subtree in the preorder traversal case
in order traversal case we first
traverse the left subtree then the root
node and finally the right subtree and
in the post order traversal case v
traverse the left subtree then the right
sub tree and finally traverse through
the root node
and finally we exit the display tree
function and move on to the main
function we assign the values 5 as the
root node then 10 20 and 30 as the left
nodes and similarly 15 25 and 35 as the
right notes and then we call the three
tree traverses that is pre-order in
order and post order to traverse the
tree and finally we release the root
note
now let us try to execute this program
and see the output
so there you go the program got
successfully executed and you can see
that the output has been displayed on my
screen so the pre-order traversal is 5
10 20 25 15 30 and 35
followed by the pre-order traversal we
have the in-order traversal that is 20
10 25
5 30 15 and 35 and finally we have the
post order traversal that is 20 25 10 30
35 15 and 5.
and with that let me give you a simple
question
so what is the pre-order and post-order
traversal of this binary search tree so
the elements are 1 2 3 4 5 six and seven
you need to find out the pre-order and
post-order traversal of this binary tree
and you can let us know the answer in
the comment sections below what exactly
is a binary tree
so it is a treated structure in which
each node can have at most two child
nodes these nodes are referred to as
left child node and right child node
next let's discuss about some terms
related to binary tree
first up a node a node consists of data
and a link towards both child nodes
next the root node root node is the
first node of the tree next leaf nodes
these are the nodes which has no child
next parent node apart from the root
node any node which has at least one
child is called as parent to that child
node next up a child node any node with
a parent is called as a child node
next up is the internal node any node
with a child and a parent is called as
an internal node next up is the height
of the binary tree the longest path from
the root to any leaf node is called as
the height of the binary tree
next up is the depth of the binary tree
the depth of the node is the total
number of edges from the root node to
the target node or the
last child node now let's try to
implement the binary tree in the code
editor
as you can see now we are on the code
editor and the code on my screen is an
example for binary tree now here you can
see that we have created a structure for
node followed by that we have a function
where we will print the tree
and this is our main function
now don't worry about the code this
particular code segment will be
available in our description box below
and you can always have access to it and
try to edit and run this code on your
own local system to have a better
learning experience now without further
ado let's try to run this program
quickly and see the output
so there you go the code got
successfully executed and here you can
see the output of this particular binary
tree
now let's get back to the theory part
so as discussed before followed by the
implementation part we will learn about
the properties of a binary tree
now let's discuss the properties of the
binary trees
first up maximum number of nodes at a
level l is 2 to the power l
next up maximum number of nodes in a
binary tree of height h is equals to 2
to the power of h minus 1.
next up minimum possible height in a
binary tree with two nodes is equals to
log of l plus 1 base 2.
next up the minimum possible level in a
binary tree with n nodes is equals to
log of l plus 1 base 2.
finally a binary tree with l leaves has
at least
log l base 2 plus 1 levels
now
let's discuss about the different types
of binary trees
first up we have the full binary tree
followed by that we have the complete
binary tree then we have the perfect
binary tree
followed by that we have the balanced
binary tree and lastly the degenerate
binary tree let's discuss about these in
detail first up full binary tree a full
binary tree is a unique tree data
structure in which a node can have
either two children or no child
next a complete binary tree
so a complete binary tree is another
specific binary tree where each node on
all levels except the last level must
have two children and at the lowest
level all leaves should reside possibly
on the left side
the next one is the perfect binary tree
a binary tree is perfect if every node
must have two children and every leaf is
on the same level
the next one is called as the balanced
binary tree
a binary tree is balanced if for each
node the height of the left sub tree and
the height of the right subtree varies
at most by just one
at last we have the degenerate binary
tree
a binary tree is said to be degenerate
if every internal node has only one
child
we have now discussed the binary tree
some terms and properties related to
binary trees and types of binary trees
now we will look into the operations
that needs to be performed on the binary
tree so there are basically three types
of operations that can be performed on
binary tree which are traversal
insertion and deletion
so first we'll look into the traversal
operations
there are three different types of
traversal operations possible on binary
tree which are pre-order traversal
in order traversal and finally the post
order traversal
now let's get back into the text editor
mode and try to execute our
example so right now we are on the text
editor and this particular code is for
the traversal operations on our
binary tree and here you can see we have
the structure for node and we have also
the in order function
pre-order function and post order
function don't worry about the code this
particular code will be available in the
description box below and after you have
written the code we have some standard
input over here you can see that we are
giving the number of edges as four and
the left subtree elements are two and
one and the right subtree elements are
two and three and another left subtree
elements are
three and five and lastly we have five
and 6 for another left subtree now let's
try to execute this code
now we have already executed the code
and we also have the output over here
and here you can see we have entered the
number of edges as four and the
traversal is inorder traversal which is
one two six five and three and the
pre-order traversal output is two
one three five six and the post order
traversal is one six five three and two
now let's get back to the ppt now we
have the insertion operation
and now let's get back to our text
editor and try to see an example for
insertion operation as well
so on my screen you can see an example
for insertion operation
so here we have the insert function
as i said this particular code will be
available
in the description box below now let's
provide the standard input
so the standard input will be four edges
and we have two and one as the left
subtree and two and three as right
subtree three and five as left subtree
again and
five and six as the left subtree now
let's quickly run this code and there
you go the program got successfully
executed and here we have the
output
the nodes got inserted and it has
provided an in order traversal that is
one two six five and three
now let's get back to the presentation
and the last type of operation is the
deletion operation let's quickly execute
an example based on deletion operation
as well
now as you can see we are on the text
editor again now here the example is for
deletion operation we have the delete
function over here
now for this particular program we don't
need any standard inputs so just let's
run the program
so there you go the program got
successfully executed and we have the
output over here and in order traversal
before deletion and in order traversal
after the deletion of an element
so the deleted element is element 11.
now with that let's get back to the
presentation mode again
so that's how the element got deleted
now we have reached to the last part of
this session that happens to be the
final key takeaways
so what are the final takeaways so
binary tree is faster at search
operations than other type of tree and
it is easier to find maximum and minimum
elements in the binary tree binary tree
does not allow duplicate values and
graph traversal is done using binary
tree it is used to convert the post
fixed expressions into the prefix
expressions let's get started with
introduction to binary search tree
binary history is a set of nodes
organized in such a manner that they all
have the same binary search tree
characteristics
a key and a value is assigned to each
node
the requested key is compared to the
keys in binary search tree
so during search if the key is found
then the corresponding value will be
retrieved
next up
properties of binary search tree
first up
the left sub tree of a node contains
only nodes with keys lesser than the
parent node
next up
the right subtree of a node contains
only nodes that are greater than the
parent node
the left and the right subtree
each must also be a binary search tree
next let's discuss what are the
operations we can perform on a
binary search tree
first up insertion
last deletion
let's discuss them in detail
first up insertion
we can insert a node in such a way so
that we obey binary search tree rules
that is the
new node should be either less than the
parent node if it's a it's on the left
sub tree or if it's on the right subtree
it should be greater than the parent
node let's execute this in the code
editor
we will start by creating a class for
the binary search tree
so class
pst
print data
and bst pointers
left
comma
right
next we will define some functions
publicly
public
first default constructor
and a parameterized constructor
a function to insert the value
and a function to traverse the node
now let's write default constructors
definition
so bst
psd
now let's write the parameterized
constructor's definition
bst
and
value
data
is equals to value
and left
is equals to null
and
right
equals to null
now let's write the definition for the
insert function
so bst
star
root
comma
and
value
now we will check if the tree is empty
or not
so if
root
then we will insert the first node
we will return
new
psd
value
otherwise we will insert the data so if
the value
is greater than
root
tata
and
then we have to insert it
in the right subtree
so
root
right
is equals to
insert
root
right
comma
value
else
else the value should be inserted in the
left
side
so root
left
is equal to
insert
root
left
comma value
and then we will return
root
now let's write the traverse function
so void
est
if
root
and we will return
otherwise we will first traverse
left side
then we will print the root data
then we will traverse
the right side
root
right
now let's write the main block
so we will start with an empty tree so
bst
b
comma
star root
is equals to
null
the root
is equals to
b dot insert
root
comma
50
e dot
insert
equals to
root comma 10
b dot insert
50
sorry we already use 50 so we will use
60
a dot insert
root
comma
let's use 20
let's try to traverse this
so b dot
traverse
root
let's execute this
as you can see we have successfully
created and traversed our first binary
search tree
let's get back to slides
at last deletion
we will delete a node following the
binary search tree rules that is the
value of the left subtree should be less
than the parent node and the value of
the right sub tree should be greater
than the parent node
let's try these in the code editor
let's start by creating a node
this time we will use structure so
struct
node
node
star left
comma
right
now we will create a utility function to
create a new binary search tree node
substruct
node
star
new node
and
item
or
star
amp
equals to
product
size of
next amp
will be assigned the key
is equals to item
amp
left
equals to null
and
damp
right
is equals to
null
now let's write
a function to traverse the tree
traverse
product
node
star
route
so if
root
is equal to null
traverse
root
left
see out
root
e
covers
right
now let's write a utility function to
insert the new node with the given key
in the binary search tree
substruct
node
star
node
comma
and
key
so if
node
is equals to null
then we will return
new node
key
otherwise
we will recur down the tree so if
e
is less than
the node key
then we will
insert in the left subtree so node
left
is equals to insert
mode
left
comma
key
else
node right
would be inserting
e
now let's return the note
now we have given a non-empty binary
search tree
so we have to return the node with the
minimum key value found in that tray
so
we will start
extract
star
men
value
node
star mode
node
start current
is equal to node
so we will loop down to find the left
most leaf
so
while
current
and
parents left
is not equals to null
so current
should be equals to
current
return
current
node star
delete
node
note star
loop
comma
and
key
f
root
equals to null
return
root
now if the key to be related is smaller
than the roots key then it lies in the
left subtree so we will check
if
e
less than
root key
then root
left
it will be equals to
delete
node
root
left key
comma key
now if the key is deleted
is greater than the roots key then it
lies in the right subtree so else
if
e
is greater than root
root
right
is equals to
delete
node
root
right
comma key
else
if
roots
dot left
equals to null
and
root
dot right
is equals to null
and return
else
if
root
that
equals to null
then struct
node
start
is equals to
root
right
and free
root
return
temp
else if
roots
right
is equals null
then stripped
outstar
temp
is equal to root
three
root
return
temp
now note with the two children
get the in order successor
smallest in the right subtree
so struct
node
star
temp
is equals to
min value
node
right
now we will copy the inorder successors
content to this node so root
is equals to temp
now we will delete the inorder successor
so root
right
equals to
delete
code
root
right
comma template
now we will return
root
now let's write the main block
we will start with an empty tree
product
node star
route
is equal to
null
now root is equals to
insert
root
comma two
route
is equals to
insert root
comma 5
root
is equals to insert
root
comma
3
root
is equals to insert
root
comma 4
root
is equals to
insert
root comma
seven
and root
equals to insert
root comma
six
let's try to traverse this so c out
traversal
of
the given
i was
root
now first we will delete a value c out
delete
two
our root is equals to
delete
node
comma
two
see out
traversal
after
deleting
traverse
root
let's execute this
as you can see we have successfully
deleted
to and traverse the tree again
let's get back to our slides
at last let's sum up what we have
learned from this session
first up left side nodes are always
lesser than the parents node and the
right side node are always more than the
parent node
next it is easier to search and sort
elements in a binary search tree
finally a binary search tree offers
faster insertion and deletion operations
what is a b plus tree
a b plus tree is a special m by tree
data structure a b plus tree of order m
can have at most m minus one keys and m
children a b plus tree can be used as b
tree with only keys to each node and
with linked leaves to which an
additional level is added at the bottom
now let's discuss some properties of b
plus trees
first up every node in b 3 can have at
most m elements
next every node except the root and the
leaf node must have m by 2 children
next maximum keys for any node is m
minus 1
and at the last minimum keys for any
node is ceiling of m by two minus one
now let's discuss what are the various
operations we can perform on b plus
three
we can perform two operations on a b
plus tree
first up insertion
second deletion
now let's discuss these in detail
first up insertion
we have to insert an element is in such
a way so that we won't disobey any
properties of b plus trees
now let's try this operation in a code
editor
we will start by creating a node to
create a node we need a struct
b plus
tree
node
and
star data
b plus
tree node
space star
child btr
boolean
leaf
and end and
for the object star root
will be equals to
null
star
and p pointer
will be equals to null
comma
star x will be equals to null
now we will write a constructor for it
so b
node
star highlight
and
i
and p equals to
mu
b plus
tree node
np arrow
data
is equals to new
space and
bracket 5.
nnp
child
ptr
is equals to new
b plus
3
node
star
bracket
sex
and belief
is equals to true
and then p at the
is equals to
zero
now we will write a for loop
i is equals to zero
i less than six
i plus plus
np
child
is equals to
return
traverse
b plus
3
node star b
out
and
i
again upon do
from i equals 0
to i
less than
p at n
i plus plus
f
p doesn't have leave
then we will traverse that child
traverse
child
patient
bracket high
see out
p data
at i
now we will check these conditions again
for
i at t at n
we will traverse it again
from p
child
at i
see out
and
now next function will be used to sort
this
so void
sort
and
for loop
a equals to pi
j less than equals to n
j plus plus
f
p bracket i
greater than p bracket j
then
we will swap these two
so temp
will store p at i
and then p will replace its value with p
at j
now we will store
the temp value in the pfj
now let's write a function to split this
child
and
set
child
e plus
3
node
star x
comma
and i
and j
made
b plus
3 node
star np1
comma
star
np3
comma
star y
and b3
is equals to
init
and p3
equals to true
f
i
is equals to minus one
mid
is equals to
x
data
bracket 2.
x data
bracket 2
will be equals to 0
then
x
will store n minus minus
p1
is equals to finite
now when p1 leave
will be equals to false
and x leaf is equal to true
for loop
j is equals to three
j less than 5
j plus
a minus three
will be equals to
x
data
j
23
child peter
at j minus 3
is equals to
x at child ptr
record j
np3
and plus plus
x
data bracket j
is equals to zero
now x
greater than
n minus minus
another for loop
from j is equals to zero
with j less than six
at j plus plus rate
x
child ptr
a j
will be stored at null
now
np1
data
at zero position
will be equals to mid
np1
child ptr
at
np1
on
will be equals to x
and p1
child
at np1
on n plus 1
will be equals to np3
even
call n plus plus
root
is equals to
np1
now else
y is equals to
x
child
ptr at i
at 2
and y
on data at 2
is equals to zero
i will store n minus minus
now for loop
j is equals to three
j lesson 5
j plus plus
np3
data
j minus 3
is equal to
y
data
a
and p3
and plus plus
y
data
bracket j
is equal to zero
why
and minus minus
x
child
ptr
at i plus 1
is equals to y
x
at
child ptr
i plus 1
is equals to
np3
return
now we will write a function to insert
into the
tree
void
insert
argument as end a
so end
i
comma temp
x is equal to root
if
x equals to null
then root
is equals to finite
and x will be equals to root
otherwise
if
x is a leaf
and
x at nine
feet and exit n
is equals to five
and temp
is equals to
split
child
x
comma minus 1
x is equal to root
f
a is greater than
x
and
a is less than
x
at data
i plus one
i plus plus
and break
else if
a is less than
x data
zero
then break
else
continue
x is equals to x at
child
at i
else
hex
leaf
is false
for loop
i is equals to zero
when
i is less than x at n
i plus plus
if
a is greater than
x
at
tata i
and
a is less than
x
and data
i plus one
a plus plus
break
else
if
a is less than x
data
break
else
continue
if
x
child
at n
is equals to five
that temp
is equals to split
child
at x comma i
x
data
at x and on n
is equals to temp
x
at n plus plus
continue
else
x is equals to x
child
right here
i
x
on data
at
x at n
is equals to a
sort
hex at data
exit n
x at n plus plus
now let's write the code for the main
block
first we will declare some variables
as and i
n
and d
now we will request
enter
number
of
element
to be
inserted
in
pattern
now c out
now we will enter the element so enter
the
element
now we will write a for loop
so i is equals to 0
to i less than n
at i plus plus
so c n
d
and insert
d
now we will traverse this
tree we'll see out
traverse
cell
of b plus 3
traverse
route
let's execute this
we will enter five elements
two comma three comma five comma seven
comma nine as you can see we have
successfully traversed our first b plus
tree
let's get back to our slides
next deletion while deleting any element
from b plus 3 we have to be careful not
to break any properties of b plus 3.
like all the leaves must be present at
the same level or elements must be in
ascending order
now let's try these operations in a code
editor
let's start by creating a b tree
first we will declare a global variable
and
max equals to 3
then we will
create a class
pp tree
and a class
node
boolean
is leaf
and
start key
comma size
load
star star ptr
and a friend class
now public
load
variable
now we will write
class
pp
void
insert
kernel
and
node star
comma
node
star
void
remove internal
paint comma
node
star
comma
node
star
and a node function
find
parent
now public
pptree
the constructor
a search function
insert function
void remove
void
display
get root
is equals to new
and
bracket max
is equal to
new
node
star
record max plus one
a bp tree
this tool
now void
with
bp tray
insert
and
x
if
rule
is equals to null
then root
is equal to
new
node
root
calls key
at 0
0
root
checks
its leaf
ice
is equals to one
else
node
cursor
is equals to root
node
star
parent
wife
cursor
is
leave
is equals to
false
parent
equals to
cursor
now for loop
and i is equals to 0
to i less than
cursor
size
i plus plus
f
x is less than cursor
key
at i
cursor
is equals to cursor
at
ptr
at i
if
i
is equals to
cursor
-1
cursor
break
now if
person
size
is less than max
then end
i is equals to 0
while
x is greater than cursor
e
set i
and
i is less than
cursor
size
i plus
class for loop
and
is equals to
cursor
at size
and j
is greater than i
a minus minus
so cursor
calls key
at j
is equals to
cursor
pulse key
at j minus 1.
cursor
calls
key
at i
is equals to x
cursor
calls
size
plus plus
pressure
calls
ptr
add cursor
size
is equal to
cursor
ptr
at
cursor size
-1
now cursor
at ptr
cursor
size
minus one
cursor
ptr
equals
else
node
equals to new
and
virtual
node
max plus one
for
and
i is equals to 0
to
i less than max
at the rate i plus plus
so virtual node
at i
is equals to
cursor
hair dye
while
x is greater than
virtual
node
mercury
i is less than max
i plus plus
for
int
j is equals to max
plus one
comma j
is greater than
i
say minus minus
virtual
node
let's see
is equals to
virtual
node
at j minus one
so virtual
node
i
is equals to x
so new
leaf
s leave
is equals to true
cursor
size
is equals to
max
plus one
by two
new leaf
size
is equals to max
plus one
minus
max
plus one
divided by two
pressure
nice
is equals to
new leaf
new leaf
new leaf
size
is equals to
cursor
ptr
max
now void
bp tree
insert
internal
x
comma node
star
cursor
comma
node
star
child
f
cursor
size
is less than max
then
end
is equals to zero
while
x is greater than
cursor
at
key
at i
and
i is less than
cursor
of size
i plus plus
for loop
and
j is equals to
cursor size
a is greater than
i
j minus minus
cursor
at key
at j
is equals to cursor
a minus one
cursor
key
cricket eye
is equals to x
cursor
size
plus plus
cursor
at ptr
bracket i plus one
is equals to child
else
node
star
internal
is equals to
new node
and
virtual
key
is max plus one
node
star
virtual
key
at max
plus one
virtual
ptr
at
is equal to zero
i less than max
i plus plus
virtual
key i
is equals to
cursor
key
foreign
and
i is equals to zero
i less than max
plus one
i plus plus
virtual
dtr
i
request to cursor
ptr
at eye
node
star
pp tree
find
parent
node
star
cursor
comma node
star child
star parent
if
cursor
is leaf
or
cursor
at
atr
zero
yes
then return
none
for loop
i less than
cursor
size
plus one
i plus plus
f
child
return
parent
else
parent
is equals to find
parent
cursor
here
if
parent
not equals to
null
return
return
now void
repeat
remove
and x
if
root
null
then
see out
empty
else
node
star cursor
refers to
root
star parent
and
left
sibling
comma
right
sibling
so while
cursor
is
leaf
equals to
false
so for
i is equals to zero
i less than cursor size
and i plus plus
current is equals to cursor
left
sibling
is equals to i minus one
right
sibling
is equals to i plus 1
if
x is less than
cursor
is
at i
then cursor
will be equals to cursor
ptr
now if
i is equal to
cursor
size
minus one
equals to i plus 2
cursor
is equals to
cursor
bracket i plus one
click
is equals to
false
zero
force
is less than
cursor
size
force
plus plus
f
cursor
key
at force
is equals to
x
then
found
equals to true
and then break
if
not found
not
done
now if
cursor
size
equals to zero
then
see out
right
delete
cursor
late
cursor
pdf
delete
cursor
root
is equals to
return
for loop
and
i is equals to
cursor
j
less than
right node
size
i plus plus
comma j plus plus
cursor
key
at i
is equals to
right node
pressure
and cursor
size
first tuner
now see out
merging
remove
internal
at
right
sibling
minus one comma
parent
comma
right node
delete
write
node
key
write node
right now
avoid
e3
display
if
cursor
is not equals to null
for
y equals to one
i less than
cursor
size
i plus
c out
handle
if
cursor
is
leave
not equals to true
and for
and i equals to zero
i less than cursor
size
plus one
ptr
now node
star bp3
get root
return root
now we will write the main block
we will start with an empty tree pp tree
node
now node
dot
insert
five
node
dot insert
15
node
dot insert
25
node
dot insert
35
dot insert
dot display
dot
get
true
node
dot remove
15
dot display
dot
root
let's execute this
as you can see
this program is working flawlessly we
have successfully deleted the key 15.
let's get back to our slides
at last let's sum up what we have
learned in this session
first of b plus trees are fast at
performing all its operations
next all the leaves must be present on
the same level and data is only stored
in leaf node
next elements of the b plus tree are
sorted in ascending order from the left
to the right
finally every node contains one more
pointer than the number of elements of
the node a brief introduction to graphs
so what exactly is a graph
so a graph is a data structure like any
other data structure example linked list
arrays etc
so graph is a little different from the
other types of data structures such as
linked lists and
arrays they are linear data structures
whereas graph is a non-linear data
structure that consists of finite sets
of vertices and a bunch of edges
connecting with them
so what are these vertices and edges so
let us understand that a graph is
usually represented by a set of vertices
and edges
so a vertice is the node present in a
graph imagine that you are a group of
five friends so each one of you is
considered as a vertex and the network
connecting you guys is known as an edge
so the overall graph of your people can
be considered as g and it is represented
by vertices and edges set where vertices
is you and the network connecting you
guys is called as an edge
so here you can see it clearly each one
of the friend is called as a vertex and
the network connecting them is called as
an edge and the entire graph is
represented using a set of vertices and
edges
now moving ahead we will understand the
graph terminologies
now at first we have the adjacency
vertices and adjacency edges so what are
adjacent vertices
if there is an edge between two vertices
that is one vertex or one node is
connected to another node directly using
just one single edge then those vertices
are called as adjacent vertices
now what are adjacent edges
if there is one common vertex between
two edges then those two edges are
called as adjacent edges let's imagine
this way let us imagine that we have
three vertexes and
these three vertexes are connected using
two edges so here we have one vertex
which is common between these two edges
so such type of edges are called as
adjacent edges
next we have the degree in an undirected
graph number of vertices adjacent to the
vertex is called as
a degree
next is the path
the path is considered as a sequence of
distinct vertices such that two
consecutive vertices are adjacent to
each other
up next we have the cycle a path that
has only one repeated vertices are
called as first and last vertices
followed by that we have the work
the term block is self-explanatory a
work is the sequence of vertices and
edges in the graph which is used to
traverse through one vertex to another
vertex
now we have entered the next segment of
this particular tutorial where we will
be discussing the different types of
graphs available
so at first we have the finite graph
so what exactly is a finite graph a
graph is said to be finite when the
number of vertices and the number of
edges are in a finite number or in a
countable number
now the next type of graph is the
infinite graph so what exactly is the
infinite graph so the infinite graph is
a typical opposite of the finite graph
so this particular graph will not have
countable number of edges and countable
number of vertices
the image here is an example for a
typical infinite graph
now followed by the infinite graph we
have the trivial graph so what is a
travail graph
a graph is said to be trivial if there
is only one single vertex without any
edges
so this particular type of graph will
only have vertex that is only one single
vertex not more than one and there will
be no edge if you have just one vertex
then there is no possibility of having
an edge unless if you have one single
loop type of edge which is connecting to
itself
but in a trivial graph we don't even
have that we just have one single vertex
so followed by trivial graph we have a
simple graph
so what exactly is a simple graph
a graph is said to be simple if there is
only one and one edge between each
vertex
so this particular example can be
considered as a simple graph so here
each and every set of vertices have one
single edge between them
now followed by the simple graph we have
the multi graph
so if there are multiple edges between
the pair of vertices then this
particular type of
graph is known as a multi graph so here
you can see that we have two vertices a
and b and we have two edges connecting
them not one but two but in a simple
graph we were supposed to have just one
edge connecting the vertices so this is
the difference between simple graph and
a multi graph
so followed by multi graph we have a
null graph
so what is a null graph a graph is said
to be null if there are only vertices
and no edges between them so remember
the trivial graph right we just had one
single vertex but no edges but here we
do have multiple vertices but no edges
connecting them so this type of a graph
is considered as null graph
so followed by null graph we have the
complete graph
so what is a complete graph
a graph is called as a complete graph
where each vertex must be connected with
the other vertices using the edges so
the meaning of this particular type of
graph is all the edges are connected to
all the other edges using at least one
single edge so here you can see a is
connected to b d and c all together with
at least one edge and similarly all
other vertices are connected to each
other with at least one single edge
now followed by the complete graph we
have the pseudograph
so what is a pseudograph a pseudograph
is a graph where at least one vertex
will have self looping type of edge so
remember the self loop or self edge we
have discussed in the trivial graph type
so this particular type of an edge where
it connects to itself is called as a
loop or kind of self connecting edge so
any graph that has this kind of a edge
is called as a pseudograph
so followed by the pseudograph we have
the directed graph
so what is a directed graph
any graph is called as a directed graph
where each edge has a direction
associated with it so so far we have
just discussed the edges which are
connecting to one or the other vertex
but there was no direction but here you
can see that this particular edge has a
direction that is from b
to a not from a to b it is from b to a
this type of edges which are directing
the traversal of the graph are known as
the directed graphs
now followed by the directed graphs we
have the regular graph
so a graph is a regular graph where each
vertex of the graph has the same degree
now here you can see all the vertices
have the same amount of degree that is
the connection between all the other
vertices so the degree of a is 3 so the
degree of b is also 3 and the degree of
d is c and similarly the degree of c is
also 3
so what i'm going to say is all of these
vertices have the same degree that is 3.
now we have the weighted graph so what
is a weighted graph a weighted graph is
where each edge holds some weight that
denotes the traversal cost through those
edges now here you can see that all the
edges have a different weight the edge
from a to b has the weight 5 and the
edge from a to c has the weight 9
and the h from c to b has 2 and the edge
a to d as eight and finally c to d as
seven so all these values are the weight
or the cost to traverse from a to
another vertex flow so from a to b we
have the cost five and a to see we have
the cost nine and similarly c to d we
have seven and so on
now followed by the weighted graph we
have the connected graph
so what exactly is a connected graph a
graph is said to be connected where each
pair in the graph is connected
followed by a connected graph we have
the disconnected graph so it is a
typical opposite of the connected graph
a graph is said to be disconnected where
each pair in the graph is not connected
to each other
now next we have the cyclic graph so a
graph is said to be cyclic if it
contains at least one cycle in a graph
that is one complete traversal
connection so a can be traversed again
from traveling a to c c to d d to b and
b to a again so this type of a graph is
called as a cyclic graph
now next we have the acyclic graph
so it is the typical opposite of the
cyclograph so here you cannot traverse
to a again by traversing from a to c c
to d and there is no connection between
d to b so the complete cycle is not
available here this type of graphs are
called as acyclic graphs
so moving ahead we have the graph
representation
so generally there are two different
ways to represent the graph data
structure
they are using adjacency matrix and
adjacency list
so what is adjacency matrix
so adjacency matrix is a sequential
representation adjacency matrix is used
to represent which nodes are connected
to
which node
if there is an edge between two vertices
then the value of the corresponding
element of the graph is one otherwise
zero if there is any weighted graph
besides then zeros and ones we can store
the weight of the edge as that
particular number suppose that there is
a connection between a and b and it is
represented as a weight of five then
there is a connection so we will use the
connection as true but we will not
represent it as one instead we will use
the weight that is 5 to represent it as
5 not as 1. if there is no weight then
we will represent it as 1 and if there
is no connection then we will represent
it as 0.
now undirected graph representation
so here you can see how we have
represented a graph so there is no
connection between a to a that is there
is no loop so the value will be zero if
there was a loop and if it was
represented with a bit then we could
have written a weight here since we do
not have weight then the no connection
is represented as 0 and a connection is
represented as 1. we have a connection
from a to b so we have represented as 1
and similarly to a to c so and so on
now directed graph representation
so the simple difference between the
directed and undirected graph
representation is we did not have a
direction in the previous segment but
here we do have directions so
b is connected to a but a is not
connected to b so we will write it as 0
because the control is traversing from b
to a but not from a to b so we need to
take care of the traversal of control so
we are representing 0 and you can see
from d to b we have one connection and
the traversal is in the direction of d 2
b so we will have 1 there so here we
have d and b so we have one so in that
way we
represent the directed graphs
next undirected weight graphs
so this was what we discussed before
instead of zeros and ones we will
represent the weight here so we do not
have a connection between a to a so that
is zero as usual but we do have a
connection from a to b so we have
represented it with a number that
happens to be the weight of the edge
and remember we do not have the
direction here this is undirected
weighted graph now if it were the
directed weighted graph then we could
have seen the direction and represented
the number with the weight
now after this let us look into the
adjacency list
so what is adjacency list
adjacency list is a linked
representation
in this representation we maintain the
list of its neighbors for each vertex in
the graph
every vertex of the graph contains the
list of adjacency vertices
area of vertices which have vertices
indexed by each vertex number for every
vertex the array element points to the
linked list of the neighbors of the
vertex so this might be a little
complicated to understand so let us
understand this using an example
so directed graph representation
implemented using linked lists
so this is the directed graph we are
using
so you can see that a is not connected
to anything so we have ended the address
of next location as x but b is connected
to a and c is connected to a similarly d
is also connected to a
so that is how we represent the
directed graphs using linked lists
next we have directed graph
representation using array
so a is not connected to anything so we
have represented as 0 and b is connected
to b as well as a so we have 1 there and
c is connected to b so c is also
connected to a so we have 2 there d is
connected to a c and b so we have 3
there
now we have the graph traversal
so graph traversal refers to the process
of examining each edge and vertex in a
graph
graph traversing can be performed in two
ways
the first one is breadth first search or
bfs algorithm bfs starts traversing the
graph from root node and exports all the
neighboring nodes then it selects the
nearest node and explores all the new
nodes queue data structure can be used
in bfs
algorithm so the following image depicts
the epfs algorithm working
it shows us the nearest node first then
it traverses to all the other nodes
so followed by bfs algorithm we have the
dfs algorithm that is the depth first
search algorithm dfa starts traversing a
graph from the initial node of the graph
and then it goes deeper and deeper until
it finds the node has no child then
backtrack from the dead end towards the
recently explored nodes stack is used
for bfs algorithms so this particular
gif image can be considered as the graph
traversal which is performed using dfs
algorithms so if you don't know much
about dfs and vfs algorithms don't worry
about that those particular tutorial
videos are added in the description box
below you can go through it and
understand bfs and dfs algorithms in a
much better way
now we will go through some of the
applications of graphs
so some of the major applications of
graphs are used in the
websites google maps and social media
websites like facebook and some security
systems
and also software programming
understanding the importance of a
spanning tree
we will have a look at an application of
the spanning tree to understand it
better
meet patrick patrick works as a head of
the network administration department in
an it solution company named as grey
solutions
being the head of network administration
department patrick is responsible for
managing his team to keep the
organization's computer network up to
date and operate it as intended
network administration department
coordinates and connects multiple
systems in the company to a single
network using multiple routers
this network is called as local area
network or lan which is created for the
sole use of an i.t company
but in the last few days something went
wrong in the network management system
which came to patrick's notice
he observed that the network loop is
formed in a routing system a network
loop occurs when multiple routes carry
information from the same source to
various computing devices
and due to this formation of a network
loop the network connectivity started
slowing down initially after a few hours
the network connectivity completely went
down and all the operations of the
company stopped abruptly
now patrick and his team needed to do
something in order to resolve this
problem permanently
so patrick started brainstorming to find
out an optimal solution to fix this
problem
one of patrick's teammate was good at
data structures and he came forward with
an idea to implement a spanning tree
data structure for managing the routing
connections
he suggested replacing the old knives
routing strategy with a minimal spanning
tree routing after listening to this
idea the whole network administration
team started working on implementing a
spanning tree
while doing that they treated the
network connection as a graph the
routers and end devices like computers
fax machines were treated as the nodes
of the graph where the connecting wires
carrying network signals were treated as
the edges of a graph
but before understanding how patrick's
team was able to solve this problem
using a minimum spanning tree let's
first understand the basics of this data
structure
this will allow us to get a clear
insight into how spanning tree solves
network routing problems so let's start
with graph and its different types
basically a graph is a structure made of
nodes and edges connecting them
and there are three types of these
graphs based on the types of edges
the first is the undirected graph the
second is the directed graph and the
last is the connected graph
let's understand these types completely
in the upcoming slides
the first type of graph that we are
going to discuss is the undirected graph
it is termed as a graph in which all the
edges does not point to any specific
direction in simpler words all the edges
of this graph will be bidirectional
as you can see in this particular graph
you can move from any node to any other
node and retrieve back as well
next up is the directed graph it is a
graph in which the edges point to a
specific direction
by this i mean in this type of graph you
can only move towards a single direction
for example you can traverse this given
graph starting from a then b
then c
then d and finally e
but here you cannot traverse back from e
to a as this graph is unidirectional
the last type of graph depending on its
edge is a connected graph
it is defined as a graph with a path
from any vertex to any other vertex in
the graph
in this particular type of graph you can
reach any vertex from any other vertex
in a graph for example you can go to
node b or d from node a and arrive back
at a from either vertex b or d
now moving ahead we will understand what
a spanning tree is and how we can create
it
mathematically the spanning tree for any
graph g having vertices v and edges e
can be represented using superscript
notation g dash having vertices v dash
and edges e dash
suppose we intend to create a spanning
tree for graph g then our spanning tree
g dash must follow a few constraints
the first constraint suggests that the
number of vertices for created spanning
tree must be equal to the number of
vertices of a given graph g
further the edges of g dash should also
be similar to the number of vertices in
graph g minus 1. to understand this
mathematical formulation clearly let's
have a look at an example
now for this given graph g we have to
formulate all possible spanning trees
remember a single connected graph can
have multiple spanning trees until we
fulfill the constraints mentioned
earlier
so for this particular graph g we have 5
vertices and 5 edges additionally each
edge has been assigned with some cost or
weight
let's say this weight represents the
distance between the connected two nodes
to create the spanning tree g dash we
need to ensure that g dash contains five
vertices and phi minus one that is four
edges
hence for this graph we can create a
spanning tree like this
you can observe that we have eliminated
one node in the spanning tree to remove
the loop or cycle in a graph
for this spanning tree one we have a
cost or value equal to 10
and this cost is nothing but the
summation of all edge weights
now that we have created the first
spanning tree for our graph g i would
like to ask all of you to give this a
try
for that i am going to provide you with
a short moment to generate all possible
spanning trees for the structure that we
are discussing right now
you can also pause this video if you
need more time in order to do that
so now let's have a look at all possible
spanning trees at a glance we have seen
that the value for the first spanning
tree was 10
and for this new spanning tree 2 it is
13. in this spanning tree the edge
between vertices b and c is removed
the next spanning tree looks something
like this with cost 14.
further we have spanning tree number 4
with a value 12.
and finally we have the last possible
spanning tree 5 with a value 11.
out of all these spanning trees the
value or cost for spanning tree number 1
is the least which is 10.
thus this spanning tree will be called
as minimum spanning tree
i hope you are clear with the creation
of spanning trees but how can we judge
the number of all the possible spanning
trees
well for that you need to check the
structure of your graph
if the graph you have been given with is
cyclic then the number of possible
spanning trees will be equal to the
number of vertices
the cyclic graph is a graph in which you
will have the same number of vertices
and edges with a cyclic structure
if the given graph is a complete graph
then the number of possible spanning
trees will be equal to v raised to v
minus 2
where v is the number of vertices in a
given graph you can say that the given
graph is a complete graph if each pair
of vertices is connected by the unique
edge
for this particular graph the number of
possible spanning trees will be equal to
the number of vertices that is 4 to the
power of 4 minus 2 which is further
equivalent to the square of 4. hence the
number of possible spanning trees for
this structure will be 16.
moving forward let's understand some
important properties of spanning tree
we have already gone through some
crucial properties while creating
spanning trees in the previous section
so primarily we will list all of them
here
the first property of a spanning tree
conveys that a connected graph can have
more than one spanning
tree the next property states that the
number of vertices in spanning trees
must be equal to the number of vertices
in the given graph whereas the number of
edges is equivalent to the mod of v
minus 1.
the third property of a spanning tree
says that the spanning tree must not
contain any cycle
if the structure that you have created
as a spanning tree includes a loop or
recycle then it's clear that you have
made a mistake because no tree can
contain a cycle
and finally the fourth property is all
about kayley's formula if the given
graph is a complete graph then you can
calculate the number of possible
spanning trees using the formula v
raised to b minus 2.
the next property of a spanning tree
conveys that a spanning tree can never
be disconnected
for example if you create a spanning
tree for this given graph which is
accurate
and you erase one edge
when you do that the structure will no
longer be a spanning tree it can only be
referred to as a disconnected graph the
next property states that if the graph
contains more than one similar weight
there is a possibility of having more
than one minimum spanning tree for
example in this particular graph there
are more than one edge having the same
weights
thus there will be two possible minimum
spanning trees with the same cost that
is seven
this is all about the properties of
spanning trees
now that you understood what spanning
tree is you would have also understood
how it proves is an effective solution
and that is exactly how patrick from our
story solved his network issue
in a few days patrick and his team
changed the naive routing into the
minimum spanning tree routing now the
routing parts are managed by a minimum
spanning tree to maintain cost
effectiveness and to avoid any looping
activity
as we have already understood misty
removes all the loops from a given graph
and we also know that the whole network
becomes the graph for which msc will
maintain a minimal routing path
hence the network system will never
experience a network loop again
due to this amazing initiative patrick
and his team were appreciated by the
whole organization
this example clearly illustrates the
importance of a spanning tree and why it
is one of the most important algorithms
in data structures
now we will look into the different
applications of spanning trees
the first application that we are going
to talk about is telecommunication
network building
if we want to build a telecommunication
network for the whole city and we are
putting different connection lines for
each customer then we will have to deal
with a huge cost
this knife ordinary approach is not the
best solution to build a connection line
but no worries this problem can be
resolved using the minimum spanning tree
data structure
in this case each customer will be
treated as a vertex whereas the
connection line will be treated as an
edge
[Music]
the minimum spanning tree will give us
the possible output for generating the
telecommunication network
no matter what type of algorithm you are
building using machine learning
techniques somewhere down the line you
will be using clustering techniques
quite liberally clustering and data
preparation go hand in hand as many
times you will be working at least
initially with data sets that are
largely unstructured and unclassified
those data sets can not be classified
using single neuron or classification
methods
so you use a clustering algorithm which
utilizes a minimum spanning tree to
create clusters or groups by mapping
distances between data points
the next application of a minimum
spanning tree is image segmentation
you must have observed that your face
gets detected with the square shape
while clicking images in selfie mode
this scenario is happening due to the
image detection algorithm developed on
the camera system
at the back end the picture gets
fragmented into tiles of similar pixels
with the help of a minimum spanning tree
the last application of the spanning
tree is its use in calculating the
finance factors
a correlation matrix can be created by
calculating a coefficient of correlation
between any two stocks
this matrix can be represented
topologically as a complex network and a
minimum spanning tree can be constructed
to visualize the relationships
now with that we have come to an end of
this session on data structures full
course if you have any queries regarding
any of the topics covered in this
session or if you need the resources
that we used in this particular session
then feel free to let us know in the
comment section below and our team of
experts will be more than happy to
resolve all your queries at the earliest
until next time thank you stay safe and
keep learning
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here
you